water
the chair recognizes the member from
auburn representative osborne who moves
the house adjourned from the session of
march 17 2022 are you ready for the
question all those favors say aye
those opposed nay the eyes have it and
the house is adjourned
the house will attend to a prayer by
guest chaplain
rabbi levi krinsky regional director of
the shabab community
thank you mr speaker i'm just going to
begin by putting a dollar in the charity
box
on the sucker box with act of kindness
i'm grateful to be here today before you
to deliver deliver the invocation of the
house of representatives in the state of
new hampshire
we're all
rightfully so concerned about the
ongoings in the situation in ukraine
many thousands of people being killed in
cold blood and millions of others forced
to flee their homes and the country
among the many cities that were affected
daily and there were just recently in
the news
was called
uh was called makalayev back in 1902
rabbi miraculem schneiderson was born
and then known nikolai of
ukraine his father i believe yitzchak
serves as the chief rabbi in what was
then known as yakatsuniya slav now known
as net nepa abushinayas went on to
become one of the generation's most
influential spiritual leaders the leader
of the khabad laboratory movement the
largest jewish organization in the world
today ukraine has 162 khabad centers
outreach centers and hosts the largest
jewish center in the world in the town
of nepa in the is known as the menorah
center
my wife and myself
for the past 32 years have been
representing the khabarovich movement
here in new hampshire and more recently
with my colleague robert moshe labe gray
in hanover at dartmouth college and my
colleague rabbi rabe beryl slovaticki
with his wife at the university of new
hampshire located of course in durham
yesterday i had the great
pleasure of being in washington dc with
hundreds of my colleagues
around from around the world
with many dignitaries and many people
attending from a bipartisan background
we were there together with many
senators members of the house to
celebrate and commemorate the 120th
birthday of the rebbe rabbi
and a blessed memory which will take
place on april 12th
rebbe's birthday is commemorated around
the united states as well as here in new
hampshire the day of education and
sharing to that end governor sununu just
recently signed a proclamation here just
this last week
establishing april 12th as the day of
education churning honor of the rebbe's
birthday remember mendel shanaerson
dedicated his life to education and
commitment to ethics and morality both
in the jewish community and beyond for
which he was awarded the congressional
mel medal of honor back
correctional medal back in 1994. he
thought that all people are created in
the image of a god and can reach the
full spiritual potential through the
adherence of the seven universal no high
laws that are that were
bind all humanity and as children of god
the talmud lists the seven laws
it mentions just to mention just a few
which include the basic prohibitions
against adultery murder and theft among
others and includes also the requirement
to establish courts of law
the god of heaven and earth master the
universe look favorably upon the house
of representatives of the government of
state of new hampshire bless these
distinguished individuals chosen by the
people of new hampshire who place their
trust faith and confidence in them to
make the laws and decisions for them and
their families let us recognize that
this is god a god-given position that is
actually in the performance of one of
the seven universal laws given to us by
god and the torah in order to ensure a
peaceful and moral society governed by
the laws that are based on the
recognition acknowledgement of you god
and the sovereign ruler of all men and
women and all nations
grant us almighty god that those
assembled here today be aware of your
presence and that by laboring and the
enactment of just laws they are
fulfilling
your will bless them with good health
wisdom compassion good share and good
fellowship may we pray that
god hasted the fulfillment of the vision
of the prophet of isaiah and they shall
be beat their swords into plowshares the
spirits into pruning hooks nations shall
not lift sword against nation neither
shall they learn war anymore
who makes peace on high may bring peace
upon us and upon all humanity and let us
say amen
the chair recognizes nicole
the chair recognizes the member from
deerfield representative terry roy who
will lead us in the pledge of allegiance
individuals
the chair recognizes nicole dox murphy
of candia who will now sing our national
say anthem
you see
by the dawn's early light
what so proudly we have
at the
twilight's last gleaming
who's brought stripes and bright stars
through the peril is
watched were so
gallantly streaming
and the rockets red glare
the bombs bursting
in
air
gave proof
through the night
that our flag was still there
oh say
does
[Music]
free
in my home
[Music]
[Applause]
the house will attend a request for
leaves of absence
mr speaker the day illness
representatives cleaver ellis mary
griffin hopper lawton leavitt lundgren
miler o'hearn timothy smith sophocetus
tudor the day important business
representative ross amanda bolden cody
cross d silvestro gorg
harrington macbeth moran o'hara schuett
vincent von plinsky woodcock the day
illness in the family representatives
eliot perez and wazir
these leaves of absence shall be granted
unless otherwise ordered by the house
house will attend to induction
introduction of guests
mr speaker please welcome connor
sengalun student at hinsdale high school
our page for the day
welcome to the new hampshire house
[Applause]
mr speaker please also welcome mona
cotter and tim hall guest and husband of
representative hall katie paterno guest
of representative pordelli
doug hanson guest of representative
gotland brett weinbrenner and ryan
vitzer guest of representative bartlett
sue lacroix catherine peppler ken kale
carmen benoit brian murphy and barbara
lyman guest of representative roy they
are with us in the gallery today
welcome to the new hampshire house
[Applause]
house will attend to senate messages
question is on the motion
chair recognizes the clerk mr speaker
the senate concurs with the house and
the passage of the following entitled
bill with the amendment the passage of
which amendment the senate asked the
concurrence of the house house bill 102
establishing a commission to study
worldwide combined reporting method for
unitary businesses under the business
profits tax in relative to the treatment
of water or sewage disposal utilities
under the business profits tax
representative major moves that we
concur and is recognized to speak to the
motion through his motion
thank you mr speaker
this bill was amended by the senate to
exempt from the business profits tax any
contribution of aid
or capital for a water or sewage project
the federal law was changed in 2017
in the infrastructure investment and job
act
to exempt contributions to aid of
construction for waterline extensions
and sewage system improvements
the department of environmental services
and the department of revenue
administration
requested the legislator update the
state's treatment
of contributions and aid of construction
for waterline extensions and system
improvements
the amendment to house bill 102 updates
rsa 77a colon 3
to mirror the federal law and thus
reducing the total cost of these
projects to
communities in new hampshire
i hope you'll support the
ways and means committee and concur on
house bill 102.
the question is on the motion to concur
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it
no motion is accepted
further send a message
mr speaker the senate concurs of the
house and the passage of the following
title bill with amendments in the
message of which amendments ascended
nasa concurrence of the house house bill
relative to the technical changes to the
administration of certain taxes by the
department of revenue administration and
relative to county redevelopment
district bonds for unincorporated places
representative major moose we concur and
is recognized to speak to his motion
thank you mr speaker
the senate amendment to house bill 1063
is a technical clarification to the
county bonding authority statute which
is essential for the redevelopment of
balsam and next decibel notch
the developer is in the process of
financing the balsam project through
goldman sachs which includes issuance of
county redevelopment district bonds
under new hampshire rsa 33 colon 20
for an unincorporated place
rsa 3320 is in conflict with rsa 28
colon 24
county bond council
the developer's lawyer
the goldman sachs lawyer and the new
hampshire attorney general all agree the
language needs to be clearer
the amendment to rsa 3320
clarifies the procedure for the issuance
of redevelopment district bonds by the
member will suspend for an
unincorporated place so the house is the
member will suspend
the house will be in order
it's extremely loud already and we just
started
member may continue
to the last part over again the
amendment
to rsa 33 colon 20
clarifies the procedure for the issuance
of redevelopment district bonds for the
county commissioners for an incorporated
place
we hope you will support the ways and
means and concur on this
thank
you the motion before us is to occur
occur
on house bill 1063 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it the emotion is adopted
representative osborne and walner
moved the adoption of an amendment to
house rule 66 adding house deadlines as
proposed by the rules committee and as
printed in the house calendar are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it in the
by the necessary two thirds and the
amendment is adopted
representative osborne and walnut moved
the adoption of an amendment to house
rule 58
regarding memorial remarks as posed by
the rules committee and that's printed
in the house calendar
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the motion is
adopted by necessary two-thirds
chair recognizes the clerk thank you mr
speaker in an emailed uh from the
chairman of the house criminal justice
and public safety committee good
afternoon mr speaker as the chair of the
criminal justice and public safety
committee pursuant to house rule 47 f
please accept this communication as a
formal request to wave off the second
committee assignment of house bill 1469
house will now attend to the consent
calendar
mr speaker from the committee on finance
house bill 1540 removed by
representative true
are there any other bills removed
president osborne moves at the consent
calendar with the relevant amendments as
printed in today's house record we
adopted are you ready for the question
all those who fail to say aye
there's opposed nay the eyes have it
the consent calendar is adopted
we're now on to the
regular calendar
part one
for a reason does a member rise
um a question of the chair
state your question i just wanted to see
that all you know
any amendments that were
that there are no all amendments are
germaine and uh for
for the upcoming uh for the rest of the
calendar
all members are all amendments are
jermaine that there are no non-german
none that i know of
thank you
majority of the committee on state and
federal relations veterans affairs to
which was referred h.r 15 and that
condemning the communist party of china
the people's republic of china having
considered the same report the same with
the following amendment the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment senator michael
buffett from the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same would be an unable
to agree with the majority report with
the following resolution that resolved
that is inexpedient to legislate senator
linda massa miller for the minority of
the committee
amendment is zero one three one h
printed in house record 12 page 39. are
you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
all supposed nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted question before us now was out
to pass with amendment are you ready for
the question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted
majority of the committee on state and
federal relations and veterans affairs
to which was written
it's getting awful noisy in a short
period of time
if you need to have a conversation
please take it out to the auntie room
uh and for those of you haven't uh
remembered turn on your voting stations
jury the committee on state and federal
relations veterans affairs to which was
referred h.r 17
an act opposing all federal and state
efforts to establish a carbon tax on
fuels for electricity and transportation
we considered the same report the same
with the recommendation the bill ought
to pass
senator william foster for the majority
of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate
representative lawrence welkerwitz for
the minority of the committee
the chair recognizes representative
harrigan to speak against the committed
report
thank you very much mr chair mr speaker
i mean
so i'm
i'm here to urge you to vote against the
ought to pass on hr 17 a resolution
opposing all federal state efforts to
establish a carbon tax on fuels for
electricity and transportation
our congressional delegation cares a lot
about we do in concord three of them are
in fact former state legislators the
fourth is a former lobbyist
and they but they do know better than
pay much attention to house resolutions
i don't think any of them will change
the votes in carbon taxation or any
other issue just because the speaker
of the house that would be you mr
speaker forwards a copy and i'm sure
will be nicely formatted of of this
house resolution
and
hr 17
is especially irrelevant because it's
ill-informed i would especially like to
highlight the last warehouse although i
think all of the i think there were six
warehouses i
think all of them were were false except
for the first one which is a rather
banel observation that it's good to have
lots of electricity
anyway the last whereas is the sole
purpose of the tax code should be to
fund necessary government functions
rather than manipulate consumer
decisions
and in my opinion that's not true at all
encouraging desirable decisions and
discouraging undesirable ones is a it's
a legitimate function of the tax code
and this statement is also inconsistent
with just about every tax policy we have
debate we have here in concord
including the like where we have at
least one about a tax cut later today
coming up
where every proposed tax cut is always
promoted as this incentive for getting
more of something or other which we want
more of
similarly although tax increases here in
concord are almost unthinkable when they
happen occasionally but you know it's
supposedly almost unthinkable
they can legitimately serve as an
incentive for getting less of something
we want less of
and and of course also this proposed
carbon taxes um there's several
proposals none of which have gone far in
congress would actually raise quite a
bit of revenue too but
anyway reducing fossil fuel consumption
is a desirable goal for many reasons um
just to name a couple
first of all there's a finite amount of
oil and gas on the earth we're going to
run out at some point we're not going to
run out of
wind or solar but we will run out of oil
and gas at some point it's often located
in convenient places such as vladimir
putin's russia
also fossil fuel consumption causes an
immense amount of pollution including
but not limited to greenhouse gases such
as carbon dioxide and
and just to say where i'm coming from
yes i do believe that uh
greenhouse
gases cause
global warming that global warming is a
problem but those first supply even if
you're not worried about global warming
um it's also untimed i know gas taxes
are double what they were two years ago
but
two years ago demand was at an all-time
low because no one was driving or flying
anywhere because there was nowhere to go
to
demand is back to normal now but now the
fossil fuel supply has been disrupted
and it will be disrupted for quite some
time by the russian ukrainian war
a minute ago i referred to putin's
russia referring of course to vladimir
putin
and
you know he yes he is a madman
but he's a madman motivated in part by
his desire to take advantage of
ukraine's fossil fuel resources it's a
it's a fairly significant fossil fuel
producer russia is one of the largest
producers on the planet
and
also
basically the only source of income that
russia has right now is oil and gas
revenues so like
he's paying for this disastrous war in
part by selling oil and gas to the west
and reducing fossil fuel consumption was
a desirable goal even in peacetime
but it's even more desirable now during
a time of war and
believe me
this is a time of war
so anyway please vote no on the ought to
pass motion to h.r 17
so that an alternative motion may be
considered
thank you very much
chair recognizes representative welcome
with speaking against community report
thank you mr speaker mr speaker i arise
in opposition to this theoretical ban on
all carbon pricing h.r 17 came to the
state federal committee because the
resolution includes banning the federal
government from imposing any tax on
carbon
i would like you to oppose h.r 17 it's a
bad out of state polluter idea it's bad
for new hampshire citizens
it's bad for our businesses economy and
our future the public opposed it
149 to 4 in the committee hearing
at first glance you might say hey any
car any tax is bad so a carbon tax must
be bad too
the inter the energy innovation and
carbon dividend act which is making
making its way through congress is an
example of legislation which would be
theoretically banned this is a federal
border adjusted cash back carbon fee on
fossil fuel fuel production including
attacks on foreign producers
economic analyses show that it will
bring cash back to most new hampshire
citizens except for big corporations and
people who fly around in in private jets
most economists including milton
friedman
agree that this type of carbon pricing
is critical towards reducing our
reliance on fossil fuels
carbon assessments are made at critical
choke points for example the points at
which foreign producers of oil or gas
create the fossil fuel when they put the
gas when they put the oil in a barrel
for example the eu canada and other
nations are adopting these types of
levees but if we can't reciprocate
it is americans and american businesses
that will be hurt explicit carbon
pricing is the only climate policy that
enables us to protect u.s businesses
while holding other countries
accountable for their pollution if this
resolution is adopted it will hurt not
help most new hampshire citizens so the
next question that we have to ask is do
we need to reduce co2 resulting from
pollution
there's a report that just came out a
few days ago by the united nations
reviewed line by line by over 200 of the
top scientists from around the world
they press code red
and as you should press the red button
on this one they press they
they press the code red button on co2
emissions from fossil fuels we're simply
at a critical point in history but h.r
17 says otherwise don't worry everything
is okay we're going to be fine and yet
not one scientific organization in the
entire world not one scientific
organization in the entire world claims
that co2 does not present a clear and
present day danger
i was born at 347 parts per million co2
we're now at 420 parts per million co2
and rising global temperatures are
rising not going down
my neighbor charlie deloz who i just
spoke to the other day has been a new
hampshire farmer and gardner his whole
life his father was a state rep from
hancock a republican back in the 60s
charlie knows the climate is changing he
sees that the lilacs are blooming three
weeks early
he sees that the sap is starting early
and isn't running into april
he knows that tick-borne illnesses are
on the rise that there are cardinals
flying around at a weird time of year he
also knows that humans are contributing
to this problem
if we can all agree that pollution is
bad that humans are creating pollution
and that pricing carbon is a way out why
wouldn't we agree that it is our
responsibility as parents grandparents
stewards of the state to vote against
this really bad resolution h.r 17
suggests a bad that is unreasonable i
urge you to vote no red button we can we
must do better
chair recognizer of minority to speak
for the committee report
thank you mr speaker
renewable energy sources suffer from two
significant problems
one they are not cost effective for base
load power
two they are not dispatchable
meaning the sun is not always shining
there is night there's clouds there's
rain there's snow there's fog
the wind doesn't always blow
or it blows too hard
small-scale hydro streams dry up for
part of the year
you cannot always rely on them
peak power demand in the coldest four
months of the year in new england occur
at night
wind turbines need to be shut down
during major storms or a nor'easter
base load
net zero carbon is impossible
unless it is nuclear
there is a climate change then there's
climate change
our climate is always changing
twenty thousand years ago we would been
under
one mile of ice
we've had global cooling global warming
now is climate change and predictions
from the ipcc climate models have been
wrong for more than 30 years
there's been no increase in catastrophic
weather
for storms
the north pole did not melt
and the polar bears are still thriving
to be sure the house will be in order
to be sure that mile of ice that was
above us did not melt from excess carbon
dioxide
i trust the ability of man to use
technology engineering and scientific
knowledge to adapt to the very slow
climate changes
warming or cooling that the planet
experiences
over the last 100 years the planet did
get one degree warmer
we survived
we adapted
we will adapt to any slow warming or
cooling in the future
climate change leadership appears to
agree to this al gore barack obama and
john kerry all have substantial ocean
front properties
watch what they do
not what they say
in order to push a more rapid uptake of
green technology in the us
despite
carbon
limits not being considered for china or
india
advocates propose a economy-crushing
carbon tax to make fossil fuels more
expensive
thereby improving the relative economic
viability of renewable sources of power
this concept is fiscally bankrupt
all you need to observe is the
disastrous impact of the current
administration's actions in throttling
gas and oil exploration production and
transportation
it is the major contributor to
tremendous fuel and electricity price
hikes we now see
this policy is effectively a carbon tax
and our citizens do not need an
expansion of that pain
advocates propose to mitigate the pain
by repeating rebating the tax to it to
our citizens
i only ask you
to consider what happened to the social
security lock box
when more revenue was needed to finance
growing financial debt the lock box was
broken
we are so lucky we don't have a
significant national debt now
vote yes and push the green button to
send this resolution to our federal
delegation thank you mr speaker
house will be in order
representative
el bel disarro has requested roll calls
that's sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
so
the house will come to order
the chair recognizes representative
welkowitz for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that hr 17 would deprive working
and middle class citizens of new
hampshire from cash back from these
penalties on fossil fuel production if i
know that h.r 17 would hurt most of our
citizens but help only the wealthiest
if i know that reducing pollution is a
high priority and if i know
that the world scientists are a better
source of information than youtube
videos would i then press the red button
and oppose this resolution
chair recognize representative votes for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker
if i know that a carbon tax would
increase the cost of gasoline
kerosene
diesel fuel
natural gas liquefied natural gas
propane
aviation fuel
even butane
and mr speaker if i further know that
increasing the cost of these fuels
would increase the cost of every product
and every service that uses those fuels
but i now press the green button
to protect the
taxpayers and the rate payers of new
hampshire thank you mr speaker
the question is on the majority motion
of what to pass on h.r 17. this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
representative tanner
representative tanner turn your station
on a vote
representative
thank you
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend the state of the vote
178 voting yay 159 voting a committed
report is adopted
for what reason does a member rise mr
speaker i move that the remarks of the
previous debate be placed in the
permanent journal
[Music]
the house will be in order
without objection
the remarks will be placed in the
permanent journal
majority of the committee on state and
federal relations and veterans affairs
which was referred h.r 18 an act urging
congress to remove the exception from
the 13th amendment
except as a punishment for crime whereof
the party shall have been duly convicted
having considered the same report the
same the following resolution resolved
that is inexpedient to legislate
president of david lundgren for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same with an enabled
agreement the majority report with the
recommendation of the bill ought to pass
representative tony lebron for the
minority of the committee
for what reason did a member rise uh mr
speaker to make a motion state promotion
i'd like to make a motion to table hr18
that is a proper motion
the motion
a division has been requested
members take your seats
great
so
the motion before us
is the tabling motion and h.r 18. it's
going to be a division vote
the chair recognizes representative for
a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr
oh i thought he was saying something
sorry mr thank you mr speaker mr speaker
if i know that this house resolution on
the 13th amendment has come to state and
federal relations many many times
and if i further know that it's time
that we move on and get out of state and
federal go to another committee where i
then press the green button to table
this bill thank you mr speaker
chair recognizes representative branch
for a parliamentary inquiry
mr speaker
if i know that the current 13th
amendment makes an exemption to allow
for state-sponsored slavery
and if i oppose state-sponsored slavery
would i now press
the red button so that we can pass this
resolution thank you
the question before us is the tabling
motion on h.r 18. this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
[Music]
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
the state of the vote
195 voting a 145 voting a
tabling motion is adopted
majority committee on transportation to
which was referred house bill 1093
act relative to the licensure of
non-resident aliens temporarily residing
in new hampshire considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that is inexpedient
to legislate president of thomas walsh
for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass present of george sikes from the
minority of the committee
chair recognized representative spike
sites to speak against the committee
report
mr speaker
and colleagues
before you vote on hb 1093
i would like to provide a human context
to the issue before us
imagine you and two of your friends
are operating a shoestring school for
impoverished children in the mountains
of haiti
sadly your efforts have come to the
attention of criminal elements
they killed one of your friends
they kidnapped you
and then they tried to demand the ransom
from the third
you were able to escape
and flee
but as the practice for the criminal
elements in this country
in order to keep them from being
discovered by police
they will then come and try and kill
you the person who escaped as well as
the friend who they tried to get the
ransom from
or imagine
if you are an afghani
or perhaps in the near future
from ukraine
when you arrive in the u.s
legally
i wish i repeat legally
you decide to live in new hampshire
and you apply for asylum
living in new hampshire you're required
to get a driver's license after 60 days
however
without a work permit you are not
qualified to get that driver's license
yet
asylum seekers will automatically
receive a work permit
after
365 days
if they have
had their if they have not had their
asylum hearing and i point out that
asylum hearings take years before they
get to them nowadays
this bill simply closes the gap
between arrival and the issuance of the
work permit
and obtaining a temporary new hampshire
driver's license as have i might point
out nearly twenty nine thousand
legal aliens temporarily living in new
hampshire
utilizing the same system of control
that that happens when the license would
expire
in the name of those who are affected by
war
drug violence
and other violent events
who have been forced to flee
all that they hold near and dear
i i urge you to overturn the committee
recommendation by pressing the red
button so that another motion may be
introduced and mr speaker i request a
division vote
we're down to the final speaker
a roll call has been requested by ribson
of del disarro was that sufficiently
seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members take your seats
chair recognizes representative walt to
speak for the committee report
thank you mr
speaker mr speaker there are plenty of
legitimate asylum applicants and the
majority of the committee has no issue
with those we believe that the current
law is sufficient
this bill would allow any asylum
petitioner to apply for driver's license
with without without work authorization
or a social security number because of a
delay
in the processing of these applications
the proponents of this bill cite covet
19 and a diversion of resources for the
delay
but i don't know maybe it's me
maybe it's the two million plus people
that cross the border last year that are
causing the delay
maybe it's the
the caravan after caravan specifically
designed to overwhelm the system that
are causing the delay
simply put mr speaker when the federal
government starts enforcing their
immigration laws then perhaps we can
look at changing ours
until then please support the committee
report of it health thank you
this will be a roll call vote
members take their seats
so
the motion before us is the majority
report of inexpedient to legislate on
house bill 1093
this is a roll call vote the chair
recognizes representative sykes for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
colleagues if i know
that it is our obligation as
representatives to try and fix the
problems that we see confronting the
people who live in this state
and if i know that this is just a
temporary
closing of a
what i might call a loophole in the
current regulations would i now press
the
red button
and
allow us to present another motion
recognize representative walt for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
believe the current law is sufficient
and if i also believe that we have no
obligation to change our laws because
the federal government chooses to ignore
theirs then would i now press the green
button
the motion before us is the majority
report of any speed to legislator and
house bill 1093 it's the roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button your opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
[Music]
represent vegan
all members president had an opportunity
to vote
house will attend the state of the vote
186 voting a 161 voting day the
committee report is adopted
majority of the committee on
transportation to which was referred
house bill 1302
fn an act relative to weighting of
vehicles having considered the same
report the same the recommendation of
the bill ought to pass senate stephen
smith for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee
being unable to agree with the majority
report with the following resolution
resolve that is inexpedient to legislate
representative kathleen wrong a bow for
the minority of the committee
the chair recognizes representative
rambo for
to speak against the committee report
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker i rise today in opposition to
the house transportation majority's
recommendation of ought to pass for hb
house bill 1302 would revise rsa 266 17
to prohibit law enforcement from
stopping and weighing non-commercial
vehicles that may be over their
permitted weight capacity
if passed the bill will take away a tool
for keeping our roadways safe without
solving any current discernible problem
under current law a law enforcement
officer may stop a commercial or
non-commercial vehicle and weigh the
vehicle the officer may employ a
stationary or portable scale or direct
the driver to a nearby public motor
vehicle scale within 10 miles
house bill 1302 would restrict that
authority to commercial vehicles only
this bill raises potentially significant
public safety concerns
the transportation committee heard
testimony from the new hampshire
department of safety division of state
police regarding the risks caused by
excessive vehicle weight which may
require police intervention
for instance a vehicle's braking ability
and steering effectiveness are subjected
to a greater failure under stress from
excess weight
tires can blow out from heightened t and
pressure that come with excess weight
in other words an overloaded pickup
truck headed to the town landfill or
transfer station can represent a greater
risk than just loose debris flying off
even though the driver may not intend or
be aware of such risk
the same is true for a family minivan
headed home from home depot overloaded
with house project supplies
while the majority suggests that the
current law is obsolete we heard
extensive testimony from the state
police that the current law is necessary
as an opportunity to educate drivers
about the dangers of driving overloaded
vehicles not just to impose citations
importantly probable cause is already
required to justify stopping and
weighing a non-commercial vehicle
indeed these vehicles are rarely issued
citations for exceeding weight capacity
the committee heard testimony from the
department of safety that such stops
have only occurred approximately six
times in the last five years and a
vehicle must also be at least 20 percent
over capacity to be given a citation
my concern is that house bill 1302 will
make it harder for law enforcement to
keep drivers safe both drivers have
overweight vehicles and drivers sharing
the road with them without evidence of
any benefit
these vehicles are already rarely
stopped for exceeding weight capacity
officers must have probable cause for
doing so
i have subsequently learned after
committee hearing from the department of
safety that should the federal highway
administration determine our law or
procedure does not comply with federal
standards we risk losing millions of
dollars in federal public works funding
as most recently occurred in 2013.
the dangers of breaking or steering
failure or blown out tires on the
highway are ones and we should and can
seek to mitigate to protect everyone on
the road
there is no testimony as to how this
bill would help residents or why it is
necessary
i ask that you oppose the majority
recommendation of otp on hb 1302 and
push the red button so that another
motion may be made
thank you mr speaker
chair recognizes representative steven
smith to speak for the committee report
thank you mr speaker
so what this bill is about is how you're
prosecuted not what the violation is
it deals with overweight
after the bill is passed you can still
get an overweight ticket what you can't
do is be ordered to drive 20 miles to
help them prosecute you that's just
insane
so mr speaker i looked up your uh
excuse me
your rev and it can hold 985 pounds
so if me and three of my buddies need a
ride you're probably overweight
a lot of you probably don't know what
your vehicle is rated to carry now when
you give us that ride if an officer
thinks that a bunch of us look
suspicious
and we might
he can pull you over and then have you
drive up to 10 miles to some scales to
see if
his suspicion that you're overweight is
correct that's wrong
commercial vehicles sure it's a
condition of their operation they have
to go out meet certain regulations a lot
of them are federal regulations but this
is about your passenger vehicle did you
know if you have a half ton pickup truck
let's say a crew cab so it's got a back
seat
half ton you put five 200 pound adults
in that you can't put a bag of potato
chips in the bed without being
overweight i bet a lot of you didn't
know that
and you didn't mean to break the law and
you could get a ticket but you shouldn't
be required to drive 20 miles to assist
the prosecution so that's all this bill
does doesn't touch commercial vehicles
you can still get an overweight ticket
now we we did hear well what about you
know the crazy guys they go down to home
depot and they have stuff loaded in the
back with a forklift
those things have weights on the bags
so if you have 20 50 pound bags of
anything they had a wicked good sale on
garden stone and you went nuts you're
still getting your ticket
so
it's improper search and seizure
they can make you drive that's wrong you
can still get an unsafe load what about
the scrap guys they're probably going to
get an unsecured ticket there's a
million ways to write a ticket we asked
the police they said yes they can do
that so
please pass the bill and stop this
ridiculous search and seizure that makes
you do a 20 mile round trip to help him
write a ticket
thank you mr speaker
senator rambo has requested a division
this will be a division vote members
take their seats
okay
the motion before us is the majority
report of how to pass on house bill 1302
this is a division vote the chair
recognizes representative value for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that this law is well intentioned
but does not address any existing
problem
and if i know that being able with
probable cause to stop private vehicles
that are blatantly operating above their
safe load limits is an important tool
for police to help
dangerously overweight keep dangerously
overweight vehicles off the road would i
now press the red button so that another
motion can be made thank you mr speaker
jerry recognizes representative walt for
a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that the department of safety
testified that if they had reason to
believe a non-commercial vehicle was
overweight they would not make them
drive to a scale because it's unsafe
they would not waste the time bringing
their portable scales there because it's
not worth it they would actually ask
them to relieve the load there which
makes this current law unneeded if i
knew all this i pressed the green button
thank you
the motion before us is the majority
report of what a pass on house bill 1302
this is a division vote you're in favor
you'll press the green button to be
opposed you press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
representative testerman
while members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend the state of the vote
199 voting a 151 voting 80 committee
reporters adopted
everybody will stay in their seats we
have a one-on-one with a division coming
up
majority of the committee on
transportation to which was referred
house bill 141
now prohibiting the disclosure of the
number of miles driven by a pacific
driver licensed by the state or vehicle
registered in the state
considered the same report the same with
the following amendment the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment senator thomas waltz
from the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate senator laura
toleski for the minority of the
committee
the amendment is 0905 h printed in house
record 12
page 22. are you ready for the question
on the amendment all those in favor say
aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it
and the amendment is adopted
the motion before us now is ought to
pass with amendment chair recognizes
representative toleski to speak against
the committee report
thank you mr speaker
hb 1401 is a bill that would keep our
mileage private from the federal
government after the recent passage of
the bipartisan infrastructure bill
and continued discussions in this body
of a mileage-based road usage fee
the minority of the committee believes
that hb 1401 goes too far by tying the
hands of new hampshire and our nation as
we try to solve the highway funding
crisis
first some background on why this is so
very important
our highway fund that builds and
maintains our state roads highways and
bridges is solely reliant on federal
funds as well as our own gasoline tax
the cost of every gallon of tax gas
includes a 23 cent tax which goes into
our highway fund to pay for the
construction and maintenance of our
transportation infrastructure now
consider that over the last two decades
new vehicles are seeing fuel efficiency
like never before a gallon of gas that
used to move a car 17 miles is now
moving that car over 30 miles nearly
twice the road usage but with the state
collecting that same 23 cents now add on
that top of that the growing number of
fully electric vehicles on our roads
that pay nothing into the highway fund
as our vehicles become more advanced and
efficient we are seeing less revenue
it's a complicated crisis that needs to
be tackled not only here in new
hampshire but nationwide
this bill is amended prevents the
sharing of vehicle mileage with any
public authority authorized to enforce
motor vehicle tax laws without the
consent of the vehicle's owner lessee or
renter
this would give a driver the choice to
opt out of having their mileage usage
shared thereby letting them decide if
they pay their fair share for wear and
tear on our roads what could possibly go
wrong with that
this morning on the other side of the
wall hb 1040 is on the consent calendar
after passing the house on a voice vote
in february 1040 establishes a
commission to study revenue alternatives
to the gas tax and the future of road
funding where undoubtedly this issue of
mileage usage will be vital to the
discussion and this bill right here hb
1401 if passed is going to complicate
that process
this is not just a new hampshire problem
this is a nationwide problem a few weeks
ago when we voted on cacr 32 nearly all
of us agreed that new hampshire is at
its core a fundamental part of something
bigger we are not an island and we
mutually benefit from being a state in
this union and because of that we have a
responsibility to not pass hb 1401
how we fund our roads at both state and
federal levels needs to change gasoline
has been the one constant for more than
a century but that has changed and we
need to approach the problem carefully
and deliberately
one of the possible tools we need in our
toolbox is mileage usage and hb 1401
takes that tool and locks it away so we
can't use it i ask that you vote no on
the committee report about to pass as
amended so that is granite staters and
as americans we can attempt to solve
this complex and multi-faceted problem
of funding our infrastructure and have
all tools available to us thank you mr
speaker
chair i recognize representative amman
to speak for the committee report
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker in 2018 80 of our state's
voters
voted at the ballot box to adopt a
amendment to our constitution article 2b
it states that an individual's right to
live free from governmental intrusion in
private or personal information is
natural and essential and inherent
and so building off of that mandate from
our
our voters we need to put those things
in the statute and so this bill is one
small attempt to put
privacy over personal information in
statute
while at the state at the same time
sending a message to the federal
government that we're not interested in
new tax schemes for our our state's
citizens
in the 1.2 trillion dollar bipartisan
infrastructure bill there is a pilot
program to
enact a nationwide mileage tax
this bill this very short bill
would prevent
our state's inspection stations and the
department of transportation from
revealing
the mileage
usage
of our state
drivers to an outside taxing authority
the bill is so short i'll just read it
and that that'll i'll wrap it up there
notwithstanding any provision of the law
to the contrary no information relative
to the mileage of a motor vehicle shall
be shared by the department or an
inspection station with any public
authority authorized to enforce motor
vehicle tax laws
without the consent of the vehicle's
owner lisi or renter
for purposes of this paragraph public
authority shall not include any entity
representing the state of new hampshire
so the state of new hampshire is free to
explore adopting a mileage tax if that's
something that we want to do here
it doesn't interfere with any business
operations such as a company called
carfax
or other companies like it that rely on
vehicle mileage data much of it not tied
to an individual
so please vote green to pass this and
tell the federal government that we're
not interested in their their pilot
program for a new tax scheme thank you
has requested a division this will be a
division vote members take your seats
jim osborne has requested a roll call is
that sufficiently seconded it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call vote
so
the motion before us as the majority
report of water passes amended on house
bill 1401
this is going to be a roll call vote
the chair recognizes representative
doleski for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that as a state and
nation we need to tackle the challenge
of how we pay for our roads and highways
and that the long-established tax on
gasoline no longer spreads the burden
equally on all users and isn't providing
the necessary revenue and if i know that
hb 1401 will prohibit the use of mileage
as one component of a multi-faceted
solution to the highway funding crisis
and that another bill on the way to
being signed is a commission that
directly deals with this issue then
would i now press the red button and
vote no on the committee report of ought
to pass as amended thank you mr speaker
the chair recognizes representative
walsh for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know the federal infrastructure
investment and jobs act contains a new
tax scheme based on mileage and this
bill is a firewall to it
if i know our citizens overwhelmingly
adopted a constitutional amendment that
insists that their personal information
remain private unless they choose
otherwise
and if i also know that this bill does
not tie the hands of future legislatures
would i now press the green button
the motion before us is the majority
reported what a passes amended on house
bill 1401 this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
[Music]
mr speaker
while memphis president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
the state of the vote
voting a 160 voting a committed report
is adopted
majority of the committee on
transportation to which was referred
house bill 1424 act relative to the
speed limit for watercraft on lake
winnipesaukee having considered the same
report the same
with the following resolution resolved
that is inexpedient to legislate
senator carol crawford for the majority
of the committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative aiden ankenberg for
the minority of the committee chair
recognizes representative bordes for
to speak against the committee report
representative waves off
chair reckon chair recognizes
representative
gagne to speak for the committed report
he weighs off also
the motion before us is inexpedient to
legislate on house bill 1424 are you
ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted
committee on transportation to which was
referred house bill 1463
also be in
order act relative to driver's licenses
issued in accordance with the real id
act of 2005.
consider the same report the same with
the following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legislate
senator ted gorsky for the for the
committee
the question before us is on the motion
of an expedient to legislate are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
division
has been requested this will be a
division vote
nobody can come in
members be in their seats
the motion before us is inexpedient to
legislate
the chair was uncertain
so this is a confirmation vote
it is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
represent vegan
[Music]
representative love
represent wolf
while members president opportunity to
vote house will tend to stay the vote
177 voting 854 voting a committee report
is adopted
majority committee on transportation to
which was referred house bill 166 fn an
act relative to the application process
for driver's licenses in the privacy of
motor vehicle records
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution a result that
is inexpedient to legislate senator ted
gorski for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report the
recommendation of the bill ought to pass
president of george sites for the
minority of the committee chair
recognizer representative sykes
speak against the committee report
mr speaker
colleagues i'd like to take a few
moments of your time to talk about what
house bill
1666 does
and what it does not do
first what the bill does
this bill will set up provisions to test
and license undocumented persons for
driving privileges
the minority believes that testing those
who might otherwise be able to drive for
more than
14 000 undocumented persons
as to their ability to drive safely is
of paramount importance
but this is a public safety measure
i want to repeat that this is a public
safety measure
over 120 people signed in electronically
in support of this bill with only eight
opposed
we have heard in the past a strong
testimony from the police chiefs
in support of this bill support which
recognizes that this bill would
greatly assist them in their
community policing efforts
the american friends service committee
the aclu as well as churches and
immigrants rights groups
also supported this bill their support
recognizes that the bill improves public
safety and provides for expanded social
and economic
justice
passage of the bill would allow many
more people to register their
automobiles and and to purchase
insurance
what the bill does not do is grant any
further privileges beyond just that
driving privileges
you will hear that persons with a
driver's license would use
this doc that document to vote the
reality is
that it will only prove a person's
identity their residence and their age
it will not
i repeat not
prove their citizenship which is the
ultimate requirement for voting
more than 17 other states have made
provisions such as this in their state
this bill will add to the efforts
previously passed by this legislature to
expand driving privileges to the people
who live in the state
for example
this house has passed it made it
possible for homeless to get a driver's
license
holders of this license will join the
already existing more than 29 000
non-citizens who currently hold driving
privileges in this state
so i urge you to overturn the committee
by pressing the red button so that
another motion may be made and mr
speaker i request a division vote
this is going to be a division vote
we're down to the last speaker so
members take your seats
senator bell disarro has requested a
roll call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote we're down to the last
speaker
members take your seats
chair recognizes representative gorsky
to speak for the committee report
thank you mr speaker
i rise in support of the committee's
recommendation
of itl
in essence if passed this bill
will allow undocumented individuals to
acquire a new hampshire's driver's
license
now in preparation for my arguments
i was reminded of a song
sung by paul simon
50 reasons to leave your lover
well there may be 50 reasons to leave
your lover
but i'm going to give you three main
reasons why this bill needs to be itled
first this bill prohibits the sharing of
motor vehicle information
to be shared to federal immigration
services
such as ice
and protection agencies
so if they suspect there's someone here
who is here illegally or undocumented
illegally
there is this bill prohibits the sharing
of information
second
integrity of elections
i disagree with my esteemed colleague
who says this has nothing to do with
voting
in testimony it was brought out
that oh no these these licenses aren't
going to be used for voting
but let me ask you how many times have
you gone to vote and you presented your
license did they do a scan of that
license to see if it was legitimate or
not
a license is a legal document
what this will do will open up the lack
of integrity at our elections
because
you cannot guarantee that a hundred
percent of the people will not use this
to vote
lastly
and probably the biggest reason it's
going to create a sanctuary state here
in new hampshire
it's going to take
the meeting of bienvenue new hampshire
to a whole new meeting
so in closing
i ask you to support the committee's
recommendation
of itl
by pressing the green button
thank you mr speaker
the motion before us is a majority
committed report of an expedient to
legislate
on house bill 1666 this is going to be a
roll call vote
members take your seats
so
the motion before us is the majority
committed report of inexpedient to
legislate on house bill 1666
this is a roll call vote the chair
recognizes representative sykes for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
colleagues
if i believe that
one of the primary directors of
our service as legislators is to provide
for better public safety
and that this bill accomplishes that by
proving that people who are driving in
this state now can drive because they've
taken a test both a written and a
practical exam
and if i believe that it is the right
thing to do for the people who live in
this state would i now press the red
button so that a new motion can be
introduced
chair recognizes representative walsh
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that this bill says that for a fee
a small fee of 150 american dollars
anyone basically on the planet can
acquire a new hampshire driver's license
without providing a social security
number
oh by the way they can't share that
information either if i also know that
this bill prohibits motor vehicle
information from being shared with any
agency that enforces immigration law
would i now press the green button thank
you mr speaker
the motion before us the majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislator on house bill 1666
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
[Music]
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
the state of the vote
189 voting a 160 voting any committee
report is adopted
we have a
wonderful class
up there sitting in our gallery
everybody
give a good wave
to our future
legislators and future leaders of the
state
[Applause]
welcome to the new hampshire house
okay members stay in your seats we've
got a the next bill is a div is a
division vote with pis only so members
return to your seats
majority the committee on ways and means
to which was referred house bill 1478
fna
an act relative to the business profits
tax applicable to the certain large
low-wage employees have been considered
the same report the same with the
following resolution resolved that is in
to legislate president of alan bernstein
for the majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill
ought to pass representative jenny
gamalo for the minority of the committee
this is a division vote members return
to your seats
who requested a roll call
it is not
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call
it's vote
so
motion before us the majority report
have been expedient to legislators in
house bill 1478
this is going to be a roll call vote
chair recognizes representative adjunct
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that this bill the
stop corporate welfare act of 2022
is this body's first effort to stop
large profitable corporations from
receiving roundabout subsidies from
medicaid and food stamps by paying their
workers low wages if i know that the
mere introduction of this bill's sister
bill the stop bad employers by zeroing
out subsidies or bezos act of 2018
was enough to make amazon raise their
starting wage to 15 bucks an hour
if i know that frustration with
corporate welfare is so bipartisan that
it is probably the single issue where
myself the cato institute and even fox
host tucker carlson see eye to eye
and if i know that ending corporate
welfare would increase wages while
saving taxpayer dollars would i now vote
red so a different motion can be made
thank you
jay i recognize representative bernstein
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know the complex and
nuanced factors that drive real and
sustainable wage growth are best left to
the invisible hand of the marketplace
not the ham-handedness of legislative
fiat
and mr speaker if i'm aware that hb 1478
would disproportionately harm low margin
labor labor-intensive businesses such as
grocery stores and retailers
and finally mr speaker if i believe that
when considering the constitutionality
of hb 1478 in the context of part 2
article 5 of the new
hampshire constitution regarding equal
and proportional tax rates
well
to be frank mr speaker let me put it
this way
if i believe that the love child of
oliver wendell holmes and nadia kamanich
could not perform the legal gymnastics
required to present a coherent
constitutional argument for this bill
would i now press the green button and
support the eighteen to one bipartisan
majority of the ways and means committee
and i t l this well-intentioned but
severely misguided bill
thank you
the motion before us
house will be in order
the majority the motion before us
majority report of any speeding to
legislator in house bill 1478 this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
represent
representative
representable flame
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
i guess you already see the results
the aes are 304 nays or 40 committee
report is adopted
everybody stay in their seats the next
one is a division in just parliamentary
inquiries
majority the committee on ways and means
to which was referred house bill 1524 fn
an act establishing a national service
alumni attraction and retention fund
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that is in expedient to
legislate
senator walter spillsbury for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative james murphy for the
minority of the committee
the motion before us is the majority
report of inexpedient to legislate
this is a division vote
members take your seats
the motion before us the majority
reported in expedition to legislator in
house bill 1524
this is a division vote the chair
recognizes representative murphy for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know
recent moody analytics in the new
hampshire fiscal policy institute
reports
show that jobs are returning to the
state of new hampshire
back to predemo back to pre-pandemic
levels but that our state is growing
older
that retirements are increasing
that a significant number of young
people are migrating out of the state
and as a result the workforce numbers in
new hampshire are still lagging far
behind
and if i know that 15 20 house bill 1524
is a three-year trial
designed to recruit and retain
dedicated and talented students and
employees to the state through a
matching grant program administered by
volunteer new hampshire which has
extensive experience
managing millions of dollars of
federally funded each year in new
hampshire
and if i know that house bill 1524
will not cost
the new hampshire taxpayers a single
penny as it will be funded by
entirely by federal arpa dollars
and finally mr speaker if i know that
the greatest challenge facing our new
hampshire businesses right now
is the lack of a robust workforce and
that house bill 1524 will help relieve
this critical shortage
would i now push the red button
on the itl motion so that another motion
can be made thank you
chair reconnaissance billberry for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
if i know that showering peace corps and
americorps alumni with up to six
thousand dollars in grants each
may sound good
but that the bill itself
even if it were
amended
is light on operational details
and lacking in clear qualifying criteria
and if i know that this bill would
earmark 750 000 dollars in fy 23
unbudgeted for individuals who are not
yet new hampshire residents
without any performance requirements or
reciprocal commitments
and mr speaker if i know that these
individuals are not more deserving
than new hampshire residents who would
love to receive similar grants
and that the best way to attract and
retain talented youth
is by adopting policies
that make new hampshire attractive for
everybody
then would i now press the green button
to support the majority recommendation
of inexpedient to legislate
thank you
the motion before us the majority
committee report have been expedient to
legislator in house bill 1524 this is a
division vote you're in favor yo
we're in the voting mode right now
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
[Music]
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
the state of the voters
hundred ninety-four ordinaier 149 voting
a committee report is adopted
i see we have another group of future
leaders
up in our
gallery up here welcome to the new
hampshire house
thank you
also be in order
committee on criminal justice and public
safety to which was referred house bill
1349-fn
enacted criminalizing the possession and
use of
silo been mushrooms
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate senator casey conley for the
committee
for what reason does a member rise
thank you mr speaker i rise to make a
motion to table hb 1349
[Music]
the motion to table is in it's proper
who requested a roll call
presenter yokela requests a roll call is
that sufficiently seconded
it is officially seconded this will be a
roll call vote
members take your seats
so
the house will be in order
the motion before us is the table house
bill 1349
chair recognized representative abbas
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know that phil
asylum mushrooms are a fungus that grow
in
moist and nutrient-rich areas
if i know that everyone
in this room knows what that means
and and lastly mr speaker i know that
after
these this fungus grows in that
nutrient-rich area people then eat those
mushrooms in order to hallucinate would
i go ahead and push the green button and
support that motion to the table thank
you mr speaker
chair recognizes representative verville
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
if i know that psilocybin mushrooms are
a non-addictive
non-toxic
compound
still in common use amongst our
population
and mr speaker if i know that the vast
majority of the voters in new hampshire
would like to see common sense reform
on non-toxic drugs
that show
excellent
use for
treating pstd and other
psychological effects
and
i i might have misspoken i apologize if
i do
and mr speaker
lastly if i know
that we should not be
creating felons
out of otherwise productive members of
society for mere possession of a fungus
that can be grown in new hampshire as
well as every one of the other 50 states
and mr speaker if i know that the state
police showed up and couldn't tell us
the last time there was any substantial
arrest for psilocybin mushrooms would i
now press the red button so we can have
a substantive debate on this topic for
criminal reform thank you mr speaker
the house will be in order
the motion before us is the tabling
motion on house bill one three four nine
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if your polls will press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
awesome
all members president had an opportunity
to vote also attend the state of the
vote
210 voting yeah 132 voting a the tabling
motion on house bill 13-49
committee on education to which was
referred house bill 1646
act relative to representation on a
cooperative school district board
considered the same report the same with
the following amendment the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment
senator melissa litchfield for the
committee
what reason does a member rise
mr speaker i rise to make a motion stage
of motion to table this bill
that is a proper motion the motion
before us is the table
house bill 1646
a division has been requested members
take your seats
so
let's get back
the motion before us is the table house
bill 1646
chair recognizes representative ladd for
a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know this bill
requires that every district have at
least one locally elected board member
on the cooperative school board
if i also know
a number of questions and concerns have
been raised regarding the status of
currently elected at-large board members
and missing details associated with the
transition and implementation process
of this bill
and lastly if i understand new hampshire
has 32 cooperative school districts
structured in accordance with 32
separate and very different articles of
agreement governing those districts
within what i then support
the tabling motion by pressing the green
button thank you mr speaker the motion
before us is the table house bill 1646
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
your post will press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
so
[Music]
represent fargo
while members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
the state of the vote
297 voting yay
49 voting nay the motion to table
house bill 1646 adopted
committee on election law which was
referred
house bill 1064 fn
act requiring the use of hand marked
durable paper ballots and elections
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is in expedient to legislate
representative wayne mcdonald for the
committee
for what reason is a member eyes
to make a motion stage of motion mr
speaker i move to table
hb 1064.
has requested a roll call is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote on the tabling motion
members take your seats
so
the motion before us is a tabling motion
on house bill 106 4. this is a roll call
vote
the chair recognizes representative
griffin barbara griffin for a
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know that the
subject matter of the legislation before
this body at this time has in part been
addressed by other legislation already
passed and further mr speaker if i know
that this bill came forward after
much discussion and a unanimous
recommendation as to how to proceed and
finally mr speaker if i know that the
tabling motion would effectuate a
support of the committee recommendation
would i now press the green button to
support the tabling motion
chair recognize representative allegro
for a parliamentary inquiry
mr speaker thank you
if i knew that the committee report
had absolutely nothing to do
with hp 1034 1064
for example if i knew
that hp 1064
had nothing
zero nothing to do with hacking of our
voting machines
mr speaker if i knew
that hp 1064
has nothing
to do with windham
except that windham is one of many
mistakes that have been made over the
past several years indeed mr speaker if
i knew
that hb 1064
really had nothing to do with the 2020
election at all but the elections
over the past several years
would i then press
the red button
so that this bill could have a few
minutes of hearing on the floor so that
you'll understand
why this bill was submitted
thank you
the motion before us is the tabling
motion on house bill 1064
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed to press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote i also tend to say
to the vote
jordan 70 voting yay 75 voting a the
tabling motion on house bill 1064 is
adopted
committing on election law which to
which was referred house bill 1473 fn
an act authorizing a forensic audit of
the november 3rd 2020 election results
in merrimack county for president
governor and united states senate races
having considered the same report the
same with the recommendation the bill be
referred for interim study senator wayne
mcdonald for the committee
for what reason does the member rise
to make a motion
state your motion
mr speaker i move to table hb 1473.
that is a proper motion the motion
before us is the table house bill
representative mueller has asked for all
calls that's officially seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members will take your
seats
so
the motion before us is the table house
bill 1473 this is a roll call vote chair
recognizes representative barbara
griffin for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that the acts desired by the
underlying bill
would be of substantial time and expense
to the state with no
outcome that would produce any change in
operations or results of elections
and mr speaker if i know
that the committee heard
testimony in regards to the underlying
issues which would have impacted one
county to a great deal
while no sponsors of the purported
legislation were willing to have their
community bear the expense and tasks in
the underlying bill
and finally mr speaker if i know that
the committee agreed that while the
purposes of this bill in regards to
elections is something to be looked at
in the future but it was not sufficient
should i now press the green button to
table this bill
the chair recognizes representative
muller for our parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know this legislative body is
tasked with ensuring that our election
process is properly vetted secure
entrusted by our voters and that the
secretary of state's report that
documents unverifiable voters who cast
ballots in the 2020 election using
affidavits in lieu of proper residential
or personal identification is nearly a
year late
in being released to the attorney
general's office for further
investigation
and if i know that information was
presented to the election law committee
that indicated our state had a statewide
statistically improbable voter turnout
rate of 92 percent during the election
and that two canvas towns had a phantom
voter rate of approximately 10 to 15
percent
and that there were a number of
questionable votes cast from memory care
elder facilities and if i know if we
believe our election process procedures
to be secure accurate and reliable then
we should be eager to perform a limited
audit so we can provide our citizens
with verifiable data rather than just
empty platitudes about our feelings
regarding election integrity
and if i know the sponsors of this bill
were happy to work with the members of
election law committee and readily
provided them with a smaller
more manageable a la carte list
weeks ago at their request of
towns and counties across new hampshire
representative this is a parliamentary
inquiry yes sir
and if i know that i actually
told a person on the election law
committee
that if it has to be my town it has to
be my town because i care about election
integrity
and finally if i know that our voters
deserve a proper up or down vote from
each of us on a more appropriate motion
and that we are abdicating our
responsibility by hiding behind a
tabling motion then would i now press
the red button so another motion can be
made
thank you
the motion before us is a tabling motion
on house bill 1473.
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you approach you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
so
[Music]
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote also attend the
state of the vote
251 voting a 94 voting a the motion
delay house bill 1473 on the table
members will stay in their seats we've
got one person speaking and then
two parliamentary inquiries
and this is going to be a roll call vote
by
once a request for roll call vote by
represent
a division is now
being requested
committee on legislative administration
to which was referred cacr24
enact the attorney enact the attorney
general
providing that the attorney general be
elected by a majority vote of the
members of the general court in a joint
session consider the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate senator janet wall for the
committee chair recognizer
representative silber to speak against
the committee report
thank you mr speaker and colleagues
the citizens of our state
have enabled
the 424 members of general court
to elect the secretary of state
on a regular basis
and the nonpartisan nature of those
elections has been shown
for many many years where
a well-known democrat has been elected
by those 424 members as secretary of
state
so this is really a non-partisan issue
the present time the attorney
general contrasted with the 424 people
who vote on the secretary of state
the attorney general is
voted into office by
four people
the head of the legislative branch and
at least three members of the executive
council
if the process
for the selection
of the secretary of state
is good enough
for the general court to do it
should it not be good enough
for our attorney general the chief law
enforcement officer of our state
the general court needs to reassert
its long neglected primacy
as set forth in the state constitution
we are a co-equal branch their
separation of powers
but the legislative branch really should
have primacy
and it's been neglected for many many
years
it's time to change that
we need this constitutional amendment we
need to take control of who our attorney
general is going to be i urge you to
press the red button so that another
motion can be made thank you
the motion before us is the committee
report vine expedia to legislate on
cacr24
this is going to be a division vote
members take your seats
so
the motion before us
is inexpensive to legislate on cacr24
this is a division vote
chair recognizes representative silber
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know
that cacr24 would provide for the
election of the attorney general by the
general court 424 members
selected by the voters of our state
and mr speaker if i know
that the present time the attorney
general is only selected by four people
would i now press the red button
to
itl or rather to
itl this motion so that another motion
can be made thank you
to overturn the itl motion sorry
jerry recognized representative roulard
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know
that since 1991
this bill has been submitted
19 times and it has failed
and if i know there's only one state
in the nation
that has the attorney general selected
by the legislator
and that legislative body and that is
maine
and if i know that the election of the
attorney general by the general court
could
increase
political pressure
for opinions from that body
as he or she may feel unduly indebted to
various state representatives and
senators
would i now
press the green button
and support the bipartisan unanimous
vote of legislative administration
vote green thank you
the motion before us is the ito motion
on
cacr24 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if your polls you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
represent petrie
thank you
represent
representative reed
i represent
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
the state of the vote
253 voting a 87 voting a committee
report is adopted
don't everybody don't go too far we got
one speaker and then we have a request
for a roll call committee on legislative
administration to which was referred
cacr25
enact
legislative term limits providing that
no person shall serve more than 15 terms
in need of the house of representatives
of the senate considered the same report
the same with the following resolution
resolved that is
an expedient to legislate senator claire
roulade for the committee
chair recognized representative lebranch
to speak against the committee report
thank you mr speaker
i rise today in opposition to the itl
motion on cacr25
the cacr simply creates a 15-term term
limit on each body of the general court
15 terms means
30 years
30 years that is a long long time
after 30 years of serving in this house
you would not be able to run for a house
seat again
but you could run for state senate and
serve another 30 years if you so choose
this cacr allows for that
now i thank
all the members here today who have
taken the time out of their lives to
serve this their communities and this
state
by passing the caacr we give the people
of the state an opportunity to say yes
or no on the idea of term limits
we should let the people determine what
they want it is not up to decide this
issue but for them because this is their
government thank you
representative abramson has requested a
roll call is that sufficiently seconded
it is not sufficiently seconded
a division this will be a division vote
members take their seats this will be a
division vote
clear
the motion before us is the motion of
inexpending to legislate on cacr 25.
this is a division vote
the chair recognizes representative
abramson for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you
mr speaker
if i know that 85 percent of americans
now support term limits including 89
percent of independent voters and every
single comment on citizens count online
if i know that entrenched career
politicians in dc and in concord make up
the leadership of both parties blocking
tax simplification and criminal justice
reforms supported by 90 percent of
granite staters
if i know that some senior members
here can't even pull off a pi and no
amount of experience is going to help
representative representative that was
out of line
probably was
don't be apologizing late
i said i'll be apologizing later
it was meant to i'll i'll get it later
representative
mister either give a proper pi or or
finish mr speaker it was intended to be
a joke i thought that would be eyes are
not a joke
right well i'll be back up later
if i if
mr speaker if i know
that someone can't get something done in
30 years in concord it's time to throw
in the towel and bring in some new
membership would i now press the red
button so we can pass term limits
chair recognize the representative hill
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know the committee unanimously voted to
deny ageism
as we are not ready to lose the
institutional knowledge of our most
valued long-standing representatives
and in the process deprive the people of
this state their choice and
representation
would i now press the green button and
support the unanimous committee
recommendation thank you
the motion before us is the itl motion
on cacr25
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're imposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
the state of the vote
301 voting yay
40 voting a committee report is adopted
the committee on legislative
administration to which was referred
cacr26
act relating to the house of
representatives providing that 100 of
the representatives are elected using
party-list proportional representation
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate presenter
christina schultz for the majority for
the committee
the chair recognized the representative
of the branch to speak against the
committee report
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker honorable colleagues i rise
today against the committee
recommendation of itl
on cacr 26
providing that a hundred of the
representatives are elected using
party-list proportional representation
let me first start by explaining what
party of this proportional
representation is
partyless proportional representation is
an electoral system that accurately and
proportionately represents the partisan
will of the people
that is
if a party receives 25 of the vote then
they shall receive 25 of the seats in
the legislature
this is done by allocating seats based
on a predetermined list of candidates
chosen by the voters such as in a
primary election
take germany for example
in germany you vote for your local
representative
but you also vote on a separate section
of the ballot for which party you agree
with most
those results are taken and the seats
allocated accordingly
this leads to more parties being
represented in their legislature
this makes it significantly harder for
parties to win outright majorities and
leads to the need for parties to build
coalitions to govern
this obviously leads to more cross-party
cooperation and less division in
government
this is the reason why maybe party-less
proportional representation is the
solution to ever creasing
increasing partisanship and division in
new hampshire
that is why i ask that you join me in
voting against the itl motion and press
the red button so that we can have a
legislature that acquire accurately
represents
the people of new hampshire thank you
motion before and i request a division
vote sorry
the motion before us is inexpedient to
legislate on cacr 26 a division has been
requested members take your seats
you
so
clearly
members will be in their seats
the motion before us is the motion of
any speeding to legislate on cacr 26.
this is a division vote
the chair recognizes representative
lebranch for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that the united
states
and the state of new hampshire are
facing increasing levels of negative
partisanship in political division
and if i know that the cacr simply makes
it a requirement that 100 out of the 400
representatives shall be elected through
party list proportional and that the
cacr is intentionally vague so that
subsequent legislation could decide what
type of party list proportional would be
used
if i know that these lists would be
chosen by the voters in primary
elections and representatives would be
elected similarly to floaterial
districts and finally if i know that
over 37 percent of registered voters do
not fit in into either major party would
i now press the red button and give the
people of new hampshire greater choice
in their elections thank you
chair recognized representative hill for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know the committee
unanimously voted to deny the suggestion
that one-fourth
of the house of representatives should
be chosen not by our neighbors and
friends but by party leaders from their
list of acceptable candidates
and if i know this scheme just seemed to
be too complicated and yet incomplete
to spring on the general public
and so mr speaker would i support the
committee report and press the green
button to itl this legislation
the motion before us is the itl motion
on cacr20 this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
hmm
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house will attend state of the
vote
320 for voting yay eight voting a
committee reporters adopted
members stay in your seats we've got one
speaker and a division vote has been
requested the committee on legis
the committee on legislative
administration to which was referred
cacr 27 enact elected and appointed
officials providing that all state
judges court judges shall be subject to
recall removal by petition and vote of
registered voters pursuant to provisions
established by the legislature being
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate senator
claire roulade for the committee chair
recognizer representative silber
for
to speak against the committee report
let's try this again
judges are appointed by four people
the governor and three members of the
executive council
once appointed
unlike the secretary of the attorney
general who has a limited term judges
terms are limited only by age they serve
until age 70
or they just resign or pass away in
office
the only way a judge can be removed
is by
impeachment and in the history of our
state the entire history of our state
there have been two
impeachment actions
one of which in the 1700s which was
dropped
the second one in 2020
in which the judge was impeached by the
house and acquitted by the senate
many of us
presumably have heard from constituents
over the past year or two
perhaps longer
about complaints about how they have
been treated
in the courts
especially in the family courts
so
while most of our judges are very wise
and thoughtful public servants
because we've heard from many com many
complaints from constituents
you really we really need to have some
mechanism
to remove a judge
where there is a groundswell of
opposition to their continuity in office
separation of powers
and the checks and balances in our
system
among the greatest strengths of our
and the three branches of governments
should serve as a check on each other
once again the general court i urge the
general court needs to reassert
its intended primacy
and eliminate the effective virtually
unlimited control of the judiciary by
the executive branch of our state
by pressing the red button
to kill the itl motion so another motion
can be brought forward and i asked for a
roll call vote
silvers had requested roll calls that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members take your seats
so
the motion before us is the inexpedient
to legislate
on cacr 27 this is a roll call vote
chair recognized representative silver
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know that many
of our citizens would like to have an
opportunity
to mount a recall provision
and if the constitution permitted it
under
procedures to be dictated by the
legislature and subsequent legislation
if i know that 19 states and the
district of columbia
have recall provisions including states
like california where judges have
justices of their supreme court have
actually been recalled by
petition recalls
would i now press the red button so that
another motion can be brought forward
thank you
jay i recognize the representative
rollout for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that technically the cacr is a
bit flawed as it references article
96 to be amended and actually amends
article 73
and if i also know
that there is no process in this cacr
it says it is quote to be determined and
quote on how the judges shall be removed
and by the way by some
future legislature
and if i know that many states
that elect
officials
and elect
judges
allow for recall
of elected officials
but do not allow recall
of judges
in the state if i know that in the state
of new hampshire we do appoint our
judges
so i'm not certain how recall
would occur
and finally if i know that this cacr
puts elected judges
in a position
of an unpopular or unpolitical decision
of a potential recall
would i vote with the majority
unanimous
vote
of legislative administration and vote
green
thank
the you before us is the inexpedient to
legislative motion on cacr 27 this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you opposed
you'll press the red button the voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
so
while members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
the state of the vote
254 of all dna 85 voting a committee
report is adopted
committee on municipal and county
government to which was referred house
bill 1155
an act relative to persons elected to a
local board serving on another board
having considered the same report the
same with the recommendation that the
bill be referred for interim study sent
a richer trip for their committee
chair recognizes representative teresa
to speak against the committee report
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker i rise today to speak against
the interim study motion
of for house bill 1155 which is relative
to persons elected to local boards
serving on another board
under current law any ex-officio member
appointed by a town's governing board
to a budget committee or planning board
or an ex-officio appointed by a school
board to a school budget committee
becomes a full voting member of the
other board
without actually being elected to that
board essentially giving a governing
board
a kind of super majority
why is this a problem
because under current law you cannot run
for local office
for two competing boards for example
let's say
joe moneybags
wants to run for both his town's
board of selectmen and town budget
committee
he's not allowed to do that because
there's a conflict of interest to serve
on both those boards
but instead joe moneybags runs for just
selectmen he wins his election
and then gets appointed as an ex officio
to the budget committee
now he can serve as a full mo voting
member of both
both boards
this is inconsistent in a loophole
because the conflict interest is still
there and he also gets to vote twice on
a town's budget
once with the board of selectmen and
again with the budget committee in
effect getting a second fight at the
apple
mr speaker this is like the new
hampshire house getting a vote on the
same bill here in the house and again
with the other body behind us
or even worse members of the other party
getting a second vote with us
last week we heard debate on house bill
1455 relative to state enforcement of
federal vaccine mandates we heard the
importance of the 10th amendment with
the concept of balance of power between
the federal government in states
we passed this bill because it was the
right thing to do and i believe the
senate has already passed it as well
so the same concept applies here
what this legislation
will simply do if we pass it would be to
change the ex official position to a
non-voting position that's it
the ex official will still serve as
their role as a liaison between between
the governing
board and other
board that they are appointed to but the
balance of power will be leveled
improving accountability of government
to the people
the intent of senate bill 2 when it was
passed was to allow towns
with municipal budget committees to have
an equal say
in the city or town budget process
members of the budget committees are
elected by the people to protect their
interests as taxpayers and to act as a
check on the governing body of the
municipality in schools
another problem under the current system
the ex-officio member often misses
several meetings in the associated
debate research and background data used
by the rest of the committee as a basis
for determining the best vote on line
items and total budget decisions
but then
comes to public hearing to vote for the
full budget the way the governing body
suggests
without being completely informed on
these details mr speaker for these
reasons passing house bill 1155 would
restore the checks and balances
eliminate the conflict the current
conflict but it would still retain the
ex-official members to the committees
assigned retaining the expertise
communication between the bodies this
would be no different than the full
house committee and subcommittees we
have here in the house hearing testimony
from many expert witnesses that
contribute their vast knowledge and
wisdom that help the
us make informed decisions
without them actually getting a vote
in summary this is common sense
legislation that provides a fair
balance upholds one person one vote
concept
and gives local residents more
accountable government
so please join me and press the red
button so that another motion can be
made and help poor old joe he's already
overworked thank you mr speaker ask for
a division vote
a division vote has been requested
we're on the final speaker members will
return to your seats chair recognized
representative van for speak for the
committee report
um i am urging you to support
the interim study because there is
plenty of statute out there which
concerns membership on various boards
also
the proposed solution makes assumptions
about
who's elected where and how the overlap
works which are not universal every town
does this differently
we think that
well this may have some merit and maybe
we should think about whether all of the
overlaps that are currently happening
are in the best interests of the
citizens that we did not have enough
information
to know whether this bill was going to
do that or not
so i would ask that you support
the interim study and maybe next year
we'll be back with a better bill thank
you
the motion before us
is a committee report of interim study
on house bill 1155 this is going to be a
division vote
members take your seats
the motion before us is the
interim study report on h.b one one five
five this is a division vote
the chair recognizes representative true
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that house bill
simply states that an elected member of
a local board or council who is
appointed to another local board
shall be appointed as a non-voting ex
official member
and mr speaker if i know that
one person one vote
is the new hampshire way
and mr speaker
if i know that even adam and eve only
got one bite of the apple
but i then press the shiny apple red
button
so that another motion can be brought
forward
thank you mr speaker
the chair recognized representative van
gluery for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
believe that the policy committee
report 17 to one believes that with
additional study we might be able to
reconcile some of the problems with this
bill and mr speaker if i believe that
there are at least three rsas that need
to be addressed and six subsections of
those rsas that need to be addressed
before this bill could be ready for
prime time then mr speaker would i
please support the policy committee
recommendation of interim interim study
and press the green button thank
you motion before us is
the interim stutter report in house bill
1155 this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if your post will press the
red button voting stations are open for
30 seconds
awesome
while members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
the state of the vote
255 voting a 83 voting a committee
report is
a little adopted mr speaker
we're on to part three
committee on finance to which was
referred house bill 1235 fn
and act relative to compensation paid to
a crime victim having considered the
same report the same with the following
amendment and the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass with amendment
senator maureen mooney for the committee
the amendment is
1170h printed in house record 12 page
22. are you ready for the question on
the amendment all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it an amendment is adopted
the question before us is the ought to
pass with amendment motion are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted as representative bean
declared a conflict of interest they did
not participate in the vote
once we get through this one we'll be
taking our
[Music]
lunch break
majority committee on finance to which
was referred house bill 1417 fn local
an act relative to payment by the state
of a portion of the retirement system
contributions of political subdivision
employees consider the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolve that it's inexpedient to
legislate
senator gerald griffin for the majority
of the committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass presenter peter leishman from the
minority of the committee
chair recognizes
representative o'brien to speak against
the committee report
thank you mr speaker i arise today
to bring forward again
a true bill
a bill that will affect the
taxpayers and political subdivisions of
our state
now why do i say this is a truly
tax payers bill
let's walk with me a little bit of the
history because you have to do this to
completely understand but i will be
brief
but in 1967 when he came up with the
nhrs the new hampshire retirement system
the state promised
in perpetuality
to pay 35 percent
to the
combined systems you got to remember at
that time there were four completely
separate groups and they combined it
into two group one and group two thirty
five percent originally it was forty
percent but was dropped down to thirty
five
that continued until two thousand and
ten at two thousand and ten
there was a great roll back by supported
by this house
that brought it down eventually from 35
percent to zero
now
where did that contributions go
it didn't vaporize
you know what you did
you wrote it right back to each
municipality and political subdivision
in this state
in in a way you created a tax
and that is paid
by each municipality
now this bill
definitely affects each
city and town
and this particular state
if you have one teacher
one firefighter or one police officer
that belongs to the new hampshire
retirement system you are paying
that 35 percent
into the nhrs
and that's coming out
of your municipal budget
and thus starving your municipality your
city and town
of what they could normally do with that
budget
now from what i understand there's money
within this state and maybe it's time to
look at it now i went to the finance
hearing and i heard many of the
architects that started this process in
but let me give you for what i have
learned and let me give you the usual
caveats
yes i am a member of the new hampshire
retirement system
a member of the national fire department
for 35 years and retired
i am also a member of the city of nashua
board of aldermen and i serve currently
as vice president of that board and i am
also on the budget committee so i have a
fair idea of what i'm talking about but
no way an expert but a fair idea
what has happened now
by the state
reneging on that original
1967 idea
has cost let's say an example of nashua
an additional 2 million dollars
now again i hear
that the state is i want to say rolling
in the dough but there is money to look
at this and there is money to come back
and to bring up the original obligations
and that original obligations was paying
35 percent
now we're not asking for the full 35
percent
we're asking for 7.5 percent
i feel
that's a compromise
that's a fair and equitable way to look
at this particular issue
now
as far as
your cities and towns
many of you
belong to or if you have
served as i do besides being the state
rep
you serve on your local town boards this
has the backing of the new hampshire
municipal associations
you may have received emails from your
school boards you may have received mail
from some of your city fathers
that are trying to tell you to support
this particular bill
this bill came out of finance very close
with the 11 to 10.
i don't find that as any mandate
as a matter of fact my personal
recommendation
is to bring this and vote positively so
we can go to the next level over to the
people that exist behind the wall
but you gotta understand what i heard in
the finance committee
is
something counterintuitive i heard from
the architects that brought this
cutback
in 2010
and i've always lived by the political
role
of when you realize you're digging a
hole
the first thing to do to survive your
political career
is to stop digging
and i'm asking you to stop digging
your cities and towns have had 11 years
of making up the 35
gap
we're only asking
to relieve that stress
to seven and a half percent
now you may not agree
with the combined
defined benefit package that's not the
issue here
this has to do with what your taxpayers
are paying
the other thing is that i want to bring
up
i will give you the example in the city
of nashua this will benefit the
taxpayers in nashua two million dollars
manchester very similar
and to your own cities in town
the city of lebanon four hundred
thousand dollars the town of litchfield
twelve thousand dollars almost thirteen
thousand dollars holding this
approximately around thirteen
thousand dollars this has an impact
so therefore i urge you to support this
and to
uh vote to override the itl that came
from the
the finance committee
and stop digging this hole
help out your cities and towns that's
our responsibility
they look to this chamber for help
so please support me and overriding this
and vote to override the the itl which
was in that committee again on the 11 to
10 decision
they need our push to help them along so
please support me in this i thank you
does the member yield to questions yes i
do
senator bell disarro you may inquire
thank you mr speaker and thank you
representative for taking my question i
was here in 2010 and when we voted my
question to you is actually a two-part
didn't we
make the employees pay two dollars more
into their retirement so we didn't
downshift and all and
does somebody from the state
sit at every city and towns bargaining
as they raise
their pay every year i mean does the
state ever say in that
i thank the representative for the
question
in 2010 when this was rolled back
there also were other things there was
questions on the ull which was the
unfunded liability well we could forget
that the ull is not attached to this
this unfunded liability as a member of
the pension system i think i speak for
everybody that is an active participant
in the new hampshire retirement system
we want as you want a healthy retirement
system
so therefore we support all the efforts
of the u uh of funding the ull which is
the promise by the year 2039
the ull will meet its
capacity and money will be rolled back
to the state maybe at that time might be
the better time to negotiate
what is the fair contribution from the
municipal city and towns but that's in
2039 many years away
which also you did is raising employees
compensation rate
such as you went from nine and
three-quarter percent as a police
officer or a firefighter to 11.88
so that means when you got your paycheck
and you went home to the wife and you
gave her the cash after you cast a check
and went out and said honey go buy the
bread
you were
2.13 percent
in arrears just by that act that was
created in 2010 so to make up that
difference
what do you think the unions would do
representative yes i think you've
answered the question
well i think and i thank the chair thank
you
the chair recognizes the representative
does the member yield to question
another question
uh it is almost lunchtime but i'm on a
roll
remember the member yields
thank you very much i appreciate you
taking my question and i hope we'll all
have something on a roll soon
i appreciate that back in 1967 um there
were there was the agreement made for to
pay 35
that actually was before my time i was
born 12 years after that i'm curious if
you know how many private sector
employees had pension plans at that time
when they voted to when they went along
with this agreement to pay 35 percent
thank you
that's a very good question
uh
you kind of missed the 80s
and what happened in the 80s a lot of
people did not really work
like they did at one time
like in nashua or at the car shop or
work in the mills where they your
grandfather or great-grandfather
probably received a defined benefit plan
but people wanted something to travel in
their briefcase as they got to
headhunter and went and traveled to get
different type of jobs
so
i would have to say and i'm quoting
the
new york times
the author that came up with the 401k
regrets
you could take my word on this but he
inventing the 401k
it wasn't the best
pension plan for everybody now what's
the benefit of a defined benefit plan
the employees put the money away
the employers put the money away it goes
into a fund and they can predetermine
and you receive
their cash it's better
than your 401k or anything like it
because you may skip a payment you may
decide to purchase the boat that's up to
you
but it's solid when you have a defined
benefit program and that's
if your question is what is the
difference that is the difference
and unfortunately the only thing left
the vestige of a defined benefit program
is mostly within the public service
sector
the chair recognizes representative
gerald griffin to speak for the
committee report
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
i rise to oppose hb
hb 14 17 would have the state pay 7.5
of the retirement system contributions
for the political subdivisions for group
ones and group two employees
the bill came out of its policy
committee
executive departments and administration
with an itl recommendation
the full house initially voted itl
it was reconsidered late in the day
after many members had left
and it passed by the slimmest imagines
the finance committee opposes the bill
on multiple grounds
the bill would change
the state policy
and the policy committee had rejected
that change
the cost of the bill is a function of
the number of employees of the state's
political subdivisions
and this
and the state has no control over that
number
in addition
this bill would encourage hiring at the
local level
and i think we all know
more hiring at the local level
results in higher property taxes
the bill's current estimated cost is
roughly 28 million
in both fiscal
and fiscal
2025.
that is after our terms of office are
off
the state may not have the money at this
time
most importantly with the effective date
of july 31
2023 passage of the bill will encumber
a future legislator's budget
and that is never good policy
and that is something we should never do
i ask that you join with us
and i deal this motion
the motion before us is enough speeding
to legislator in house bill 1417.
are you ready for the question
roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
members take your seats
the motion before us members take your
seats
the motion before us is the majority
committed report of inexpedient to
legislator in house bill 1417.
chair recognizes representative leishman
for parliamentary inquiry
good afternoon mr speaker
mr speaker
if i believe the rep from nashua that
spoke in favor of overturning the ltl
on 1417 got it all right
and mr speaker i know that yesterday
yesterday state revenues exceeded plan
by 230 million dollars and the rainy day
fund presently has
257 million dollars in it
and finally mr speaker
knowing the state's financial situation
wouldn't i support providing a modest
7.5 percent
contribution which works out to 28
million dollars to our municipal family
and vote red
against the itl motion thank you mr
speaker
chair recognizes representative weiler
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know
that the state has not made
contributions to local employers
retirement shares since 2012
due to the unpredictability of the cost
and if i further know
that the 28 million in the bill wouldn't
go very far among one point three
million people if that makes it about
twenty dollars per person and with about
two point five people per home that
might bring it up to fifty dollars
however
thirty three percent of the property
taxes are paid by businesses and 18
percent by second homes so you cut it in
half again
about 25 dollars per person which
i know would quickly evaporate in the
year-over-year tax increases from every
town please press the green button
and do away with this false promise
thank you
the motion before us the majority
committee reported in expenditure
legislator and house bill 1417
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you press the green button if you
oppose you press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
the state of the vote
163 voting 882 voting a the motion
foreign expedient to legislate fails
representative leishman moves
ought to pass
mr speaker i arise it's it's already
made representative leachman moved on to
passage thank you mr speaker
are you ready for the question
i was waiting for that
roll call has been requested is that
sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded
hey
we don't need
the motion before us now is ought to
pass on house bill 1417.
this is a roll call vote chair
recognizes representative wilder for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know
that this
seven and a half percent will do nothing
to help the unionized employees that are
participating it gives them nothing and
if i further know that the small
difference it makes
in the
towns will not do anything to affect the
property taxes would i now
vote red
on this proposal
recognizes representative o'brien for
parliamentary inquiry thank you mr
speaker mr speaker if you know
that this bill could be called the
taxpayers bill with 2022
by alleviating the burden that was
vacated of the 35 down to zero to our
municipalities and our political
subdivisions and if i know that with
coven and other things that went on this
past years that our municipalities are
cash stopped and could use a break on
other important things such as education
and other issues facing municipalities
then would i not support
the green
press agree button are about to pass
thank you mr speaker
the motion before us is ought to pass on
house bill 1417 this is a roll call vote
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
so
representative
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
also attend the state of the vote
186 house will be in order 186 498 159
voting a
minority criminal committee report of
autopass is adopted
for what reason is a member rise
i'd like to have a move on
reconsideration having voted on the
prevailing side
the motion before us is reconsideration
on house bill 1417.
and i asked that
you vote no on reconsideration
can i get a division and the division
has been requested
the motion before us
is reconsideration on house bill 1417.
this is a division vote members take
your seats
uh
the motion before us
is reconsideration if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
opposed you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
this is a division vote
representative
representative petrie
[Music]
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote household 10 state
of the vote
164 voting 882 voting a reconsideration
fails
we're got a couple of announcements in
the unanimous consent so just
stay in your seats for a minute chair
recognizes representative goalie for our
announcement
thank you mr speaker
members of the legislative sportsman's
caucus are invited to lunch next door at
the upper marker house and anyone else
interested in learning more about the
caucus uh come on over and we'll have uh
representatives from fish and game
department there as well as a director
as our guests thank you
chair recognizes the clerk for
announcement thank you mr speaker there
are binax now tests ready for pickup in
your anti-room mailboxes and are
recommended for use prior to our next
house session uh most likely in april we
realize that many of you have an ample
supply of test kits at home however any
feel free to take them any unneeded test
kits can be deposited in the marked bin
with signs on it that is in the anteroom
next to the trash bin please do not put
them in the trash bin but the smaller
bin next to it and the test kits that
are not picked up on session day today
will be mailed to you
i recognize representative abramson for
unanimous consent
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker i rise for uh unanimous
consent for an apology a few minutes ago
i made a remark that was uh meant to be
an inside joke
regarding a member of this house who's
been here a long time and has uh some
difficulty with parliamentary matters
um that was meant to be an inside
um
i don't know i was up until four in the
morning working on uh floor amendments
and speeches and things and so i'm kind
of going on three hours of
sleep but uh
i should have spent more time looking at
the
at the pi i only spent a few minutes on
it and i i
should have
given more time and thought to making
sure that the wording was correct so
but i apologize to that member i think
he knows who he is and i apologize to
the members of the house for wasting
your time with a point that
probably wasn't related to the bill
itself
okay it's 20 past
we will reconvene
at 1 30.
committee on finance to which was
referred house bill 1462fn
an act relative to motorcycle learners
permits have been considered the same
report the same with the recommendation
that the bill ought to pass
senator lynn turcotte for the committee
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye those opposed nay
you guys have it the committee report is
adopted
committee on finance to which was
referred house bill 1526 fn
act relative to income eligibility for
in and out medical assistance having
considered the same report the same with
the following amendment the
recommendation to build out a password
amendment
senator jess edwards for the committee
amendment is 1181h
printed in house record 12 page 23. are
you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted the motion before us now is the
ought to pass with amendment on 1526 fn
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the guys haven't committed reporters
adopted
that's that's just to read out
committee on finance to which was
referred house bill 1535-fn
house will come to order
an act relative to cost of living
adjustments for retirees in the state
retirement system to give the city the
same report the same with the following
amendment recommendation that the bill
ought to pass with amendment
senator william hatch for the committee
the amendment is one one five one h
printed in house record 12 pages 23-24
the debate is going to be on the
amendment chair recognizes
representative adjunct to speak against
the committee amendment
thank you mr speaker
i rise today to oppose the committee
amendment on hb 1535
because put simply i like the underlying
bill
new hampshire's hurting right now with
high gas prices brought on by supply
issues
oil companies in a devastating european
war the burden is being born by lower
income and retired granite staters just
like it was in two thousand eight
our seniors need help
these people did not get their pensions
for nothing but rather they contributed
decades of their lives to our state our
communities and our municipalities
they have given so much and now they sit
in their homes cutting medications
because they can't afford to re-up
prescriptions
visiting friends less because they can't
afford the gas
eating less healthfully because the
nutritious food they need costs more at
their age
they are the biggest recipients of the
pressures of inflation
wisely a bill was introduced to this
house which provided for a cost of
living adjustment for these folks and i
want to thank those who worked on it i
liked their plans so much that i voted
for the 1.5 cost of living adjustment
the first time that i came through this
house and passed on a voice vote i would
like to do it again
there was a concern in the finance
committee about the cost of the bill
and it's true 79 million dollars is a
heck of a bite
it's an argument that would resonate
with me had this body not voted two
weeks ago to cut the business profits
tax
or if the ways and means committee on
the other side of the wall wasn't being
encouraged to cut business taxes by
nearly 70 million dollars i.e the cost
of the underlying bill
or had the business profits tax cuts not
been included in the 2021 state budget
or the triggers in the 2019 state budget
or the 2017 state budget for the last
five years the state has cut hundreds of
millions of dollars in taxes for the
best performing biggest often out of
state businesses who especially during
the pandemic made massive profits as a
result of the upward redistribution of
wealth we saw where these companies were
the only games in town as small
businesses were shattered
they didn't need more help
yet the legislature saw fit to write
checks in the forms of tax breaks to
them
funding this cost of living adjustment
would be a fraction of the money that we
have thrown out in the form of corporate
tax breaks and even despite that
revenues show we have the money to pay
for the 1.5 percent unless we continue
to give it away
i firmly dismiss the idea that we can't
afford to support seniors as we keep
shoveling out money in the form of
corporate tax cuts
the amendment only offers a one-time
payment but is insufficient in the face
of year over year inflation
a 2021 poll published by newsweek showed
that 80 of americans were bothered that
the wealthy and well-off corporations
don't seem to pay their fair share in
taxes i believe that's consistent in new
hampshire
the desire to see the wealthy and pay
their fair share comes from the desire
to fund necessary things like supporting
our seniors
i believe that because i've seen
communities rally together to spend
money on things that they valued
like my own newfound area school
district who in 2021 when faced with
slashing school sports and programs that
students and parents alike valued as a
result of the fda school lunch
calculation organized and made the
appropriations to support those students
and those programs and i am making the
same value judgment in support of our
retirees and as such i'd ask the house
for an opportunity to vote on the
underlying bill without the committee
amendment thank you
chair recognizer representative hatch to
speak for the committee report
thank you mr speaker good afternoon
honourable members
and first let me say that i don't
at all disagree with the previous
speaker but we are in the reality
reality of this world
house bill 1535 establishes a cost of
living adjustment
of one and a half percent
for
anyone for the first thirty thousand
dollars
of the benefit
for those who have retired at least
sixty months prior to july 1st 2022
the committee received a lot of
testimony about the hardships many
retirees are having
in the current economy
but because of the 70 i believe at 72.2
million dollar cost
the committee found it not practical to
pass the non-budget year and that was a
lot of the objections when
there's resistance to open the budget
so what the committee voted to do
in lieu of the fact that it's a budget
year
amended the bill to give retirees
with less than 30 thousand dollars of
benefit
a one-time 500 payment to help them with
the current conditions the thought was
that you know maybe they can fill their
fuel tank or
take care of some other necessities that
they're having hardships with so with
that i i ask you to please pass this
amendment thank you
mr speaker
question before us is amendment 1151-h
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted the motion before us now is
ought to pass with amendment are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
a division has been requested members
will take their seats that are in the
chamber
we're already in the in the voting mode
for a division
this will be a division members take
their seats this will be a division vote
to clarify
the voice vote
nope can't come in
so be a division vote for clarification
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
represents flaning
representative andrews
representative anderson
represent peterson
represent bergeron
representative langley and
representative snow thank you
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend the state of the vote
218 voting 100 voting a committee report
is adopted
senator paul bergeron michael moffatt
louise andrus wayne mcdonald
and ned gordon and joe shapiro did not
vote did not participate in the vote for
the conflict of interest
majority of the committee on finance to
which was referred house bill 1552 fn an
act
establishing a board for the
certification of excessors
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpensive to
legislate senator peter leishman from
the majority of the committee
minority of the committee have been
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report the
recommendation of bill ought to pass
senator maureen mooney from the minority
of the committee
chair recognizes representative mooney
to speak against the
committee report
so
oh
for what reason does a member rise
for a motion mr speaker stage emotion to
table okay
that is a proper motion the motion
before us is the table house bill 1552
a division
has a roll call has been requested is
that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
okay
so
also be in order members will be in
their seats
the motion before us is a tabling motion
on house bill 1552
chair recognizes representative
leitchman for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know the members of the finance
committee had questions but didn't get
all the answers they were looking for
and mr speaker if i know since the itl
motion more questions have arisen
without answers
and mr speaker if i know this bill
creates a new fee and fines
that i believe should have gone to the
ways and means committee for vetting
and finally mr speaker since a
bipartisan majority doesn't believe this
bill is ready for passage
wouldn't i vote to table
house bill 1552
and press the green button thank you
chair recognizer representative maguire
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that the policy of creating
this new board passed the edna committee
unanimously and passed the house
on a very strong voice vote those on
consent
and if i know that the assessing
standards board which is the technical
advisory
for
the assessing profession strongly
supports this bill
and if i know that the fees that will be
charged simply cover the cost as with
all other professions
rather than being buried into the dra
budget
and if i know that this bill creates
much greater transparency
in the operation of the assessors would
i not press the red button so we can
proceed to the bill
the motion before us
is the tabling motion on health bill
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
representative bale
all members president opportunity to
vote house will attend the state of the
vote
124 voting a 221 voting nay the motion
of the table fails
we're now back to the majority motion of
inexpedient to legislate chair
recognizer representative mooney speak
against the committee report
thank you mr speaker and colleagues of
the new hampshire house
i rise in support of the minority of the
finance committee for ought to pass on
house bill
by means of some background this bill
was
unanimously requested by the assessing
standards board
it came out of the executive department
and administration committee
unanimously again
and through this full house on a voice
vote on the consent calendar
as it stands now
the assessing standards board exists
under the department of revenue
also known as the dra
under that department it has no fees
currently for certification
nor is there government transparency if
an assessor obtains
or loses
a certification
under the dra
such transparency is not there
and this was a primary reason for the
introduction of the bill
this bill establishes the board of
certification of assessors
within
the office of professional licensing and
certification
that known as
oplc
the oplc currently oversees over 50
boards
under the oplc
the board of certification of assessors
would be self-funded by fees
just like
other boards now
under the oplc
for example
home inspectors
land surveyors
real estate appraisers
and real estate brokers
and
transparency of certification
decertification both
would be required
again
as with other boards under the oplc
now
bottom line
is that the board of certification of
assessors should not be treated
differently from other certification
boards
two additional points
first when it comes to fees they will be
nominal with no impact on the taxpayer
and with regard to appeals
under the dra
an appeal process is currently described
as
difficult
and without due process
establishing the board within the oplc
will allow for a disciplinary process
that includes hearings
an appeals process
and
transparency for decertification
in conclusion
i would ask that you support this bill
to establish the board of certification
of assessors
where it belongs
that is
under the oplc
by voting red
on the itl motion so another motion
can be made
thank you for your attention and mr
speaker while i'm here i would request a
division vote at the proper time
thank you
chair recognizer representative leishman
speak for the committee report
thank you mr speaker
so let me put some of the facts out
there with the finance committee
majority looked at and had concerns with
this bill
first of all there's no disagreement
with what the speaker just said
about transparency
the fact of the matter is there's a
senate bill senate bill 53 that
addresses the issue of transparency that
is headed for the edna committee in the
next week or two
the department of revenue administration
took no position on this bill
but they did reach out to me after i
sent an email after i received several
emails from people questioning the
motives of the members of the finance
committee that supported itl
and i'd just like to
read briefly one part of a quote and i
think probably all of you have received
this email and it disturbed me because
my colleagues on the finance committee
like all of us here do our jobs and do
it thoroughly
so one of the assessors that wrote to us
again
after we held the work session and may i
add that nobody attended our work
session that was an assessor there was
one individual there
the director of the licensure board
and a representative from the dra that
took no position
but after i've
after we voted and after
i wrote the menu the majority report for
the committee
this is what was being said about our
actions
i find out that there
had to be some kind of back door
politicking because now it is
recommending itl
there was no backdoor politicking
senate bill 53 would take care of the
transparency issue without any fees or
fines
and that mr speaker concludes my remarks
thank you
motion before us is the majority report
of an expedient to legislate this is
going to be a division vote
members take your seats
here
clear
the motion before us is the majority
reported in expanding the legislator on
house bill 111552
this is a division vote chair recognized
representative emerick for parliamentary
inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that the assessors would
prefer to be treated like a professional
organization and not a subset of the dra
and if i also know that currently
the general fund pays all of their fees
for certification unlike any other
professional organization would i now
push the red button so another motion
can be made thank you mr speaker
i recognize the representative leachman
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i believe that bipartisan group of
finance got this right wouldn't i press
green and support the bipartisan vote of
the finance committee on 1552 thank you
motion before us the majority report of
innings speaking to legislators on house
bill 1552 this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
representative
thank you
represent langley
all members president had an opportunity
to vote
also attend the state of the vote
88 voting a 258 voting nay the majority
committee report fails
representative mooney moves minority
report about a pass
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the
house will be in order the eyes the eyes
have it in the minority report of water
pass
committee on finance to which was
referred house bill 1587 fna act
relative to determination of average
final compensation
under the retirement system and making
an appropriation therefore considered
the same report the same with the
following amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass what amendment in gerald griffin
for the committee amendment is one one
six nine h printed in house record 12
pages
26-27
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes haven't the committee amendment
is adopted the motion before us now is
ought to pass with amendment are you
ready for the question all those favors
representative requests a roll call is
that sufficiently seconded
it is not sufficiently seconded
the question before us
is the ought to pass with amendment are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and committed report is
adopted
representative
andres declared a conflict of interest
and did not participate in the vote
committee on finance which was referred
house bill 1604 fn an act including
state medical facilities
and the statute providing medical
freedom and immunizations considered the
same report the same with the following
amendment the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass with
presenter of jess edwards for the
committee
the amendment is 11608 printed in house
record 12 pages 35 and 36.
uh are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
suppose nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted the emotion before us now is the
ought to pass with amendment are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes haven't and committed reporters
adopted
committee on finance to which was
referred house bill 1609
fn
act relative to the scope of fetal
protection act having considered the
same report the same the following
amendment a recommendation that the bill
ought to pass with amendment senator
jess edwards for the committee
the amendment is 1209 h printed in house
record 12 page 36.
the debate will now be on the amendment
the chair recognizes representative
wolper
to
speak against the committee report
against the amendment
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
i rise in opposition to this amendment
primarily because
if i speak directly into it
okay we'll speak directly into it
this amendment adds one thing to the
fetal life protection act
fetal anomalies are fetal abnormalities
incompatible with life
so i think it's important that we think
about where we are
when this comes into play
we have
a family we have a mother a baby
likely other family members
the baby is six months old
the family is surprised at the fact that
there is an abnormality in the baby
they're concerned
it takes time to find out what's going
on
it's not unlikely
that they'll be well past the 24 war to
24 weeks
when an actual decision can be made
so the question is
how do we make the decision
what are we actually deciding
and what we're deciding
is
is it okay
to intentionally
kill
that baby
to intentionally kill it
there's no problem if the baby dies
during kinds of treatment for example
one of the things most commonly recently
referred to in this context
is twin to twin transfusion syndrome
first of all that's not a fetal anomaly
both neither the fetuses
has any anomaly
it's a problem with the pregnancy
so this amendment
wouldn't even deal with it
but just in case it did think about this
we use that expression fetal anomalies
incompatible with life
and it's mostly a self-fulfilling
prophecy
it's a diagnosis
and the diagnosis is often wrong
we heard lots of testimony
as this year as we have in past years
of children
diagnosed with fetal anomalies
incompatible with life
but they don't die
they are born
very normal
some with some disabilities
many without
and they live
they live for years or decades
but yet the phenomenally incompatible
life would say that's not possible
yet we know it is
that's because the baby's not a
diagnosis
the baby is a living
human being
so
if that that being the case
why would anyone want to make that
diagnosis
who makes that diagnosis anyway
is it the mother
father
no usually it's a medical professional
or a group of them
why would they make such a decision
why would they give that diagnosis
what does that doesn't diagnosis again
really mean when you say fetal anomaly
incompatible with life
do you mean that
the baby is going to die
well we're all going to die so i don't
think that's it
do you mean it's going to
first of all the baby's alive
so it's not totally incompatible with
life
does it mean that the baby's not going
to survive after birth
well it could mean that
but what does that mean does it mean the
baby won't survive for
five minutes
five hours
five years
what does that mean
i don't think we know
so i went looking for it as preparation
for this and you know what there is no
definition out there
there's no medical definition of what
this means
because it's not definable
so what happens now
now we open the door
to when any
well to what i want to say with medical
professionals and i don't want to um
denigrate the medical profession
but
there are varying degrees of um what i
want to call it
ethics within that profession
and there's a lot of pressures that are
on them
pressures from people like insurance
companies that don't want to pay for the
length of the pregnancy or potential
complications that might arise later on
from
people who think that
various conditions
aren't worth living with
like for example down syndrome
and we see in the world
in countries like denmark and iceland
where they be proudly proclaiming that
they've nearly eliminated down syndrome
from their population
because they abort any baby that has
that diagnosis
and down syndrome might be
incompatible with life in some cases
but in most cases not so much at all
so this is where we are these are the
doors that we're opening
we're opening the door to killing
children there's no reason why by the
way that needs to be done
for any female
abnormality at this age
there are options
the first option is often
even though it's not the best medical
treatment
like for example in the in the case of
twin to twin transfusion syndrome the
first medical option is delivery you can
just deliver the babies
now remember where we started we started
24 weeks
by the time you get to 30 weeks
you can deliver a baby and there's
virtually no
uh negative consequences that come from
that the babies are born normally
and they're born and they and they live
just the way they would
otherwise
but since time has gone on we're at 26
27 weeks maybe even later
when we're actually deciding whether or
not to do these abortions they should
never be done
just deliver the babies would be a lot
better off
but they can be done and they can be
done
for practically any reason
because it's all in the judgment
of the one making the diagnosis
for that reason mr speaker
i find this
both unnecessary
and harmful and i urge you to vote
against the amendment
chair recognized representative edwards
to speak for the
amendment
thank you mr speaker and
thank you fellow colleagues i was an
enthusiastic supporter of
hb2 and the insertion of the fetal life
protection act
part of my belief in that was that by
waiting for the 24 week mark
i had been informed that all relevant
diagnostic tests could be done in time
so that by the 24th week the mother
would make an informed decision
on what she wanted to do about keeping
the baby or terminating the baby
now although i spent over 40 years as a
health care administrator i'm not a
provider i have a lot of respect for the
provider community and um and so
as as as we left that vote and its
insertion in hb2 i was feeling pretty
good about it
but
the stories and the truths and the
realities
came
over the transom
and i think most of us are aware of the
woman who informed us about her twin to
twin
transfusion syndrome scenario
where
one twin it was wasting away
and
in the failing of that child was
increasing the risk of harm and death to
the other and so
under
hb2 if if that scenario was happening
after the 24th week
we
would be saying no
to that mother and to that physician
that you cannot
take the one to save the other
this is the kind of solomon choice
that i think government ought not to
make
we have
medical professionals who train
patients
that you got to assume after 24 weeks
they probably would like to keep the
baby
but
when it comes time to make that decision
i think we need to trust
the process the process is
the physician and the patient go through
an informed consent process
that informed consent process makes sure
that the patient knows their
alternatives
and then that patient has an opportunity
hopefully with their their their partner
their male partner to make a decision
together about raising or bringing that
child into the world or terminating at
that point i don't think we should be in
the exam room with them when they're
having that conversation
and so this amendment adds
fetal
anomalies incompatible with life
down syndrome
does not fall into that definition
okay so
this is not
allowing a back door to abortions of
convenience
this is about
letting the medical profession
treat their patient at that time
so
this is a major part of this amendment
i hope you can support this part of it
and vote yes
the other part of this we've you know i
think
most of us have agreed to which is
that
the original hb2 language around
ultrasounds always made it such that
the ultrasound wasn't required until
there was a
precision determination around the
24-week gestation period
this repeats the language that's in the
penalty sections up in the body of the
text so that there can be no longer any
incidental or intentional
misinterpretation of the ultrasound
requirement
so i think it's a i think it's a good
amendment
i think it's something that
the new hampshire house can be proud of
if we pass it so with that mr speaker i
would ask for a division vote
the motion before us is on the amendment
1209 h
a division has been requested
roll call has been requested by
representative walper is that
sufficiently seconded
it is not sufficiently seconded this
will be a division vote
so
my
the motion before us
is
the amendment 1209 h
this is a division vote
the chair recognizes representative
walper for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know we've heard
testimony after testimony
of parents who were given diagnosis of
fetal abnormalities
incompatible with life who against
medical advice
have bore their children to find out
that they were fine
and if i know mr speaker
that
these abortions are used across in other
countries to eliminate entire classes of
people
with a now vote
against this amendment by pressing the
red button
chair recognizes representative lynn for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker if i
know that this amendment makes two very
important changes to the fetal life
protection act which we passed last year
if i know that first the amendment
clarifies what was always the intent of
the original law
that an ultrasound is not required in
every case where an abortion is sought
but only in those cases where there is a
genuine question as to whether the fetus
has attained a gestational age of 24
weeks or more and if i know that second
the amendment creates an exception to
the 24-week ban on abortion
for those tragic situations where a
medical professional determines that the
fetus suffers
from an abnormality that is inconsistent
with the fetus's ability to survive and
live
leaving the heart-wrenching decision of
whether to have an abortion in such
cases to where it should be
with the mother in consultation with her
husband or partner and her doctor then
would i press the green button so that
these measured and entirely reasonable
changes to the fetal life protection act
may be enacted thank you mr speaker
the motion before us is on the amendment
h
this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
so
[Music]
all members president had an opportunity
to vote house will attend the state of
the vote
319 voting yeah 25 voting a committee
amendment is adopted
the motion before us now
is ought to pass as amended
on house bill 1609
for what reason does a member rise
thank you mr speaker to make a motion
state your motion
to table house bill 1609 as amended
that is a proper motion
a division has been requested members
will take their seats
yes
is
clear
the motion before us is the table house
bill 1609
this is a division vote
chair recognizes representative love for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i knew that this bill amended as
amended has no language for our
requirement for for a legal clinical
burden of proof
regarding fetal anomalies incapable with
incompatible with life and if i knew
that it is in fact safer to induce labor
or do a cesarean section allowing for
the birth of the baby and let nature
take its course would i then press the
green button to take the table house
bill 1609
recognizes representative wolf for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that the committee report on
this bill was 21 to pass as amended and
mr speaker if i also know that this
amended bill has strong bipartisan
support and the support of the public as
well
and finally mr speaker if i know
that the law as amended is absolutely
critical
to patients like lisa who many of you
have spoken with
would i then now press the red button to
overturn the tabling motion thank you mr
speaker
the motion before us
is to table house bill 1609 this is a
division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
so
[Music]
representative hamm
while members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
the state of the vote
101 voting yay 243 voting a the tabling
motion fails
we're back to the
motion of autopass as amended
chair recognizes representative simon
speak against the committee report
thank you mr speaker
i think we can all agree that a
diagnosis of a fetal anomaly
incompatible with life is devastating
and heartbreaking news so
just know that i feel that way as well
since debate about the fetal life
protection act began we've been assured
by new hampshire abortion providers that
abortions this late in pregnancy rarely
happen
and when they do
only because of a fetal anomaly
incompatible with life
according to nhpr however there is not a
single medical provider in the state of
new hampshire who claims to even perform
abortions after twenty four weeks
as recently as two weeks ago sandra
dunacore the executive director of
lovering health center was quoted as
saying that abortions aren't done after
22 weeks six days in the state of new
hampshire
there's a full week before the fetal
life protection act even applies
she also said that the fetal life
protection act is a band with no purpose
other than to work backwards from
so actual abortion providers say that
the fetal life protection act has no
purpose and is practically speaking a
ban on something that doesn't even
happen in new hampshire
if the fetal life protection act isn't
affecting actual medical practice then
one wi-fi against it
additional exceptions to this law
um appear to have no purpose
other than to uphold the deeply
ingrained conditioning
that killing innocent children is a real
and necessary good
and that is the best solution for
eliminating so many of our problems
let me offer a less and moral less
gruesome
and less lethal solution
abortion as defined in the law is any
procedure that will with reasonable
likelihood cause the death of the child
i believe there is a procedure that can
address the concerns of fetal anomalies
incompatible with life without
necessitating the direct killing of the
child
by 30 weeks a child has a 99 chance of
survival if it is born with no
discernible increase of long-term
negative health ramifications due to the
early delivery
inducing and delivering a child at this
stage does not fall under the definition
of abortion in the statute
remember these are pregnancies where the
life and physical health of the mother
are not at an elevated risk the fetal
life protection act already contains
robust exceptions for the physical
health and life of the mother the law
does not require that a mother sacrifice
her life or even the long-term integrity
of her body and its functions for those
of the child
furthermore late term abortions are more
complicated and dangerous for the mother
than regular birth
why else would every hospital in the
state refuse to do them
why take the extra unnecessary step of
killing the child first why not induce
labor and give the child every possible
chance to live and let god determine
what is incompatible with life
what does a fetal anomaly incompatible
with life actually mean
if the anomaly
was currently incompatible with life the
child would be dead
if the child were dead then the child
could be removed from the mother in a
medical procedure that does not fall
under the rsa definition of abortion
but the child is not dead
the child is still alive
so a fetal fatal fetal anomaly diagnosis
does not pertain to the child as it is
but to the child as a medical
professional professional assumes it
might be sometime in the future
when in the future
after the first breath
a few days after
a few weeks
months
in what time frame must the death occur
for some condition to be incompatible
with life
every person in this room will
experience at some point a condition
incompatible with life
however no medical provider even knowing
the exact condition can predict exactly
when you or i will run out of time nor
can they exactly or infallibly predict
the life or death outcome for pre-born
children
there are plenty of testimonies of
parents who after receiving a fatal
fetal anomaly diagnosis have still given
birth to children who lived some of whom
who lived completely normal and healthy
lives
what if they had believed the faulty
predictions and chosen to kill their
child
my solution granted of waiting to induce
labor at 30 weeks has elicit elicited
concern about the psychological strain a
mother might endure by carrying the
child a few extra weeks after receiving
a fatal anomaly diagnosis
however many women who choose abortion
rather than birth in such circumstances
carry the burden
of psychological strain not only for a
few weeks but for a lifetime
always wondering if the diagnosis was
accurate or if they made a tragic
mistake
there is a fundamental difference
between losing a child to natural
circumstances and actually giving the
order to take their life
abortions committed based on fallible
medical judgments or self-fulfilling
prophecies
a doctor says a child will be dead
and so the doctors make that child dead
a baby is now dead by a doctor's
diagnosis in action but there is no
postmortem autopsy to verify that that
diagnosis was accurate it can only be a
deadly unfalsifiable claim
as a result misdiagnosed fully viable
children are killed
no one is held to account and the
mothers question and grieve
does the diagnosis of a likely but still
only potential outcome give anyone the
right to preemptively kill a child
never
how we view life matters
a child may only live for as long as
it's in its mother's womb but while it
is there it is still alive
is the value of life simply a matter of
function of utility of perfection
are not all people miracles even if
their first breath is their last
the baby may not be perfect fully
functional or have any utility in the
future but while it lives it is is it
not nonetheless a miracle is it
nonetheless a person
every breath is a precious breath
whether we take one or millions we all
want as many living breaths as we can
get
as we sit here today breathing freely
alive till our last breath can we justly
deny an innocent child that same
opportunity
either all human life has intrinsic
value because it is made in the image of
god or none of it does no matter its
flaws
no matter its brevity
so in conclusion
what will we do with children who are
less than perfect in form or function
who certainly face difficult challenges
in the future or who may not even make
it past their first breath
i say let them live mr speaker
for as long as they are able
let them live
thank you
chair i recognize representative edwards
speaking favorite committee report
thank you mr speaker
i think we've had
months and months to think about where
we're at right now
and so
i will just conclude
by asking you to pray
settle yourself and press the green
button
presentable disarro has requested a roll
call as that's sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call
i can see vote
okay
the motion before us has ought to pass
as amended on house bill 1609
this is a roll call vote
chair recognizes representative bell
disarro for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i believe
that i've lived with this for many many
years
on abortion from a girlfriend
in my dreams and other stuff on what
that child will be like and mr speaker
if i only knew
i would adopted that child
and mr speaker
if you believe as i do that
this bill
takes away the great work we did in hb2
and mr speaker in closing
i hope every one of my fellow
republicans stand tall
and vote this bill down so we can make
another
[Music]
amendment
thank you
the chair recognizes
chair recognizes representative umberger
for a parliamentary inquiry
chair
chair recognizes representative lin for
a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker mr speaker as uh if
i know as representative as a
representative from auburn has said that
we have all given great thought to this
matter
and that
and if i know
that much of the comments that were made
by by our friends on the other side of
who spoke who had a different view on
this
really dealt with the question of what
really sort of overlooked i guess i
would say the question of
the right of the woman to make the
choice in these terrible terribly
difficult situations of of you know the
the the uncertainty that that that we've
that we've heard about
then i would ask you shouldn't that
question in these very very tragic
situations be left to the woman to make
to make her own decision on this
i submit to you it should thank you mr
speaker
the motion before us is on ought to pass
as amended on house bill 1609
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
mr speaker
baltimore mr president an opportunity to
vote
also attend state of the vote
231 voting 114 voting a committee report
is adopted
committee on finance to which was
referred house bill 1624 fna act
relative to students with disabilities
participating in co-create co-curricular
activities making an appropriation
therefore consider the same report the
same with the following amendment the
recommendation the bill ought to pass
with amendment senator bob lynn for the
commit for the committee
the amendment is
1166hp in house record 12 pages 36-37
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes haven't the committee amendment
is adopted the motion before us now is
ought to pass with amendment are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
committee re the eyes haven't committed
report is
all right mr adopted
here we go
so
committee on finance to which was
referred house bill 1 house will be in
order
1627 fna
an act establishing an education freedom
account program administrator and
department of education and making
appropriation therefore
having considered the same report the
same with the following amendment a
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with amendment senator mary heath
for the committee
thank you mr speaker
not yet
the amendment is
1163h printed in house record 12
page 37
the chair recognizes
representative warden to speak against
the amendment
thank you mr speaker
colleagues this bill
passed out the original policy committee
on a vote of 18-1 and was put on the
consent calendar
that shows bipartisan support for a
sound idea in regards to the educational
freedom accounts
but for some reason the finance
committee added a non-german amendment
that has nothing to do with the fas but
rather ties us
to some federal program
for tracking families for free reduced
student lunches and breakfast
it would require our state department of
education
to
work with the
medicaid department and the
usda and
tracking the children of new hampshire
and
in regards to qualifying for financing
for free and reduced lunch
but why would we get in bed with the
departments in washington d.c
all them are used as political weapons
against those out of favor
they are borderline corrupt at worst
and totally ineffective at best
do you love the epa
how about osha
medicaid is no different
it's a vast morass of ineptitude and
bureaucracy so why would we want to get
closer to them
and the usda
that is the government entity that told
you what to eat based on the food
pyramid you remember that
for a decade they told americans to eat
a diet based on grains bread cereal and
pasta that department should be
dismantled
here in new hampshire partisans of all
stripes cry for more local control
whether in regards to masks in schools
or zoning
local local local
even at the state level we are proud to
thumb our collective noses at the feds
such as with today's bill to sell
cannabis in state-owned stores
even though marijuana is still
a schedule one felony level
drug at the federal level
but now this amendment goes the opposite
direction demanding that our state
department of education work with usda
on a demonstration program
no thank you
besides the fact that it's an unproven
demonstration program
we should all be very concerned about
the very real potential for privacy
violations if enacted
new hampshire residents your
constituents
overwhelmingly and enthusiastically
passed a constitutional amendment to
protect their personal privacy
to provide thousands of families
personal financial information to
another group of faceless nameless
bureaucrats in washington is a terrible
concentration of power is a dangerous
slippery slope we don't want washington
d.c managing our affairs and tracking
our children
let's reject the urge to expand the
nanny state and do the right thing for
the people of new hampshire by rejecting
this amendment thank you mr speaker
the member from salisbury representative
andrus is recognized to speak
against the amendment
representative
is she here
thank you mr speaker
i am opposed to the amendment 2022
1163-h and the new section application
for medicaid and certification program
my first opposition is to the cost that
will occur for the taxpayers which is
estimated to increase expenditures 60
million dollars annually
next part 1 article 2b of the new
hampshire constitution states
an individual's right to live free from
governmental intrusion in private or
personal information is natural
essential and inherent
would this amendment violate a person's
privacy where information from medicaid
individuals is to be shared by the
department of education united states
department of agriculture and department
of health and human services and without
their knowledge
for whatever the reason a family may
decide they do not want to be a part of
the program but will be enrolled
automatically i am asking you to vote no
on this amendment thank you
the member from hudson representative
proud is recognized to speak against the
amendment
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker i rise to oppose the majority
committee amendment on house bill 1627.
i have no objection to the good work of
the finance committee in making slight
adjustments to the appropriation in the
original bill
and the effective date thereof
in fact you may notice another amendment
in your c pocket that restates this
aspect of the majority committee
amendment that could be adopted should
this amendment fail
however i do object to section three of
the amendment which was added following
a rushed non-germain amendment hearing
this new program could cost the state up
to 60 million dollars annually
but it's not just the price tag i object
to
this new program undermines parental
rights violates the privacy of students
and their family and imposes new new
burdens on local school districts
what this program does is sets up a new
automated data sharing between medicaid
and school districts
they'll start sharing data about
households including their income with
local school districts who then need to
compare that data against their student
list
this processing isn't magical
it isn't free
it's going to take some work and
therefore resources and money to do that
a new burden on school districts
this program is based on a flawed
assumption
the assumption that anyone who has not
applied for a government handout
failed to do so by mistake
this program assumes that everyone wants
free government handouts food in this
case
maybe the family is well aware of the
program but has chosen not to
participate
this program makes no provision for an
opt out or other way to say leave me
alone
a family may do this because they don't
want their child eating the cafeteria
food and prefer to send a packed lunch
from home
maybe they have strong opinions about
organic or no non-gmo food
maybe their child has a condition like
celiac disease or fetal
yeah pku
maybe their child has a weight problem
and they're preparing a specific diet
maybe they're trying to follow a
religious dietary restriction
it isn't for us to second guess the why
parents should be
in charge unless they ask for help
and the application for free and reduced
meals is the way they do that
i'm incredulous that this program is
needed because free and reduced meals
application would be too hard for
parents to fill out when this program is
predicated on the assumption they've
already filled out the application for
medicaid
it's the same documentation for both
but this isn't just a bad idea in
general it's an especially bad idea
right now
why right now because during the
pandemic the federal government
suspended medicaid eligibility testing
and just funded the over-enrollment that
occurred by not revalidating enrollee
eligibility
all the data in the medicaid system is
as
of the household's last application or
revalidation
which may have been two years ago
this problem has been in the news and
recognized as a huge undertaking for
states to reactivate their validation
programs and work through the backlog
so here we are about to launch a new
program to to violate families privacy
trigger huge new stay outlet
state outlays and the data we're going
to base the whole system on is well
known to be absolute junk right now
we could not have picked a worse time to
launch this program
even if you believe there is a good time
to launch this program which i don't it
certainly isn't now
i ask you to press the red button to
vote no on this amendment so that
another motion can be made that will
preserve the good work of the finance
committee on the original topic of the
bill and we can send that and only that
onto the body on the other side of the
wall
thank you mr speaker
does the member yield for a question
yes
representative leon you may inquire
thank you mr speaker
i've looked into this program a little
bit because it seemed like it might be
able to streamline things but when i
found out that places like california
where a county has the same number of
students as us
but they only have 20 school districts
and we have 200 school districts do you
think that this plan that works first
for states that have very large school
districts would actually be a
time saving and cost saving process in
new hampshire or do you think it might
be more of a burden on our school
districts
thank you for the question i think your
question hits on one of the key aspects
of this that to automate anything is a
big outlay in it costs and assumes you
have automated systems and people to run
those automated systems and for a very
large school district like the ones you
mentioned in california
they have that they can there's the
economies of scale to do all that that's
not true of a lot of school districts in
new hampshire and it's going to the
burden on them is going to be very
different
than it would have been on those larger
districts in california
the member from manchester
representative heath is recognized to
speak in support of the amendment
sorry mr speaker i was conferring
mr speaker
i stand before you to support amendment
this motion originated in a bipartisan
committee made up of members with the
house finance and house education to
better calculate free and reduced lunch
numbers used in determining state
adequacy funding for school districts
this amendment does two things first it
provides funding for the education
freedom account administrator for fiscal
year june 30th to 2023 to administer the
education freedom accounts within the
new hampshire department of education
the position is critical to oversee and
manage the millions of dollars awarded
to new hampshire students from the
education trust
secondly this amendment authorizes the
new hampshire department of education
and health and human services to seek
participation in a demonstration pilot
for medicaid direct certification
administered by the u.s department of
agriculture
the department of education reports that
participation in the pilot will better
will result in better information
about the number of children eligible
for free and reduced lunches less
paperwork for school districts and the
poorest of new hampshire children will
have better access to free and reduced
lunches
simply it's a win-win situation for
children
it'll give us more accurate count to
count the children and i ask for your
support on this amendment
i also want to mention that the in the
literature that we see from the
department of education they gave us a
general cost of 60 million dollars and
that 60 million dollars was not
subtracted from the amount of money that
had already that already goes into the
adequacy formula so that was somewhat
misleading again i ask for your support
this is this is a good thing for us to
do amendment number 1163 thank you mr
speaker
yep
the questions on amendment 11 63 h
representative umberger requests a
division vote this will be a division
vote members please take receipts
uh
i also come to order members take your
seats please
the question is on amendment 1163-h
this is a division vote
[Music]
so this is division vote okay
the question is on amendment 1163-h
representative wharton is recognized for
a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that new hampshire
families not government bureaucracies
should be preparing kids for school
and if i know that we as a legislature
should be promoting self-reliance and
independence not
expanded welfare programs that we can
ill afford
and if i know that we cannot count on
the feds to protect granite stater's
privacy
and mr speaker if i know that our
constituents want a free state not a
nanny state would i now push the red
button to defeat this amendment
the house will be in order
representative umberger is recognized
for parliamentary
inquiry thank you mr speaker
this bill has gotten all sorts pardon me
representative sorry if i know
excuse me
that this bill has gotten wrapped around
the axle 15 times
and is not what
the folks speaking against it
really does
this bill simply
gives the
doe
the ability to
check with usda
and see if we can qualify
for the demonstration project
and if i know
that none of this will go into effect
until 2025
and that we have all kinds of
opportunity to change it if that's what
you want to do
then would you please press the green
button
the question is on amendment 1163 this
is a division vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
opposed you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
so
have all members president an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
182 in the affirmative 148 in the in the
negative the amendment's adopted
now we are going to have a series of
one-on-ones on amendments so please
don't go far
for what purpose does a member rise to
make a motion mr speaker state your
motion i moved the table
hb 1627 fna
representative platt moves that house
bills 1627 be laid on the table this
will be a division vote members take
your seats
who requested the roll call
representative silvia requests a roll
call it is sufficiently seconded this
will be a roll call
for vote
where
i also come to order the question is
whether to lay house bill 1627 on the
table this is a roll call vote
representative plett was recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
mr speaker if i know that we are facing
quite a few additional amendments to
this bill
and time is being chewed up
and if i know that if we could come back
with a clean one in the future
should we not wait for that moment and
table it for now thank you
representative umberger is recognized
for parliamentary inquiry
i'm reminded table by pushing the green
button
folks
if i know
that we just passed the amendment
to
which means you all
support what's going on
if i know
that i did not add these amendments
they were added by you
not me
and if i know that the reason we may
have to stay here
is not because of me
but because of you
the house will come to sir
if one
mr speaker if one would think i was a
little
angry you might be absolutely right
but again
please
do not
under any circumstances
push anything but the red button thank
you
the question is whether to lay a house
bill 1627 on the table
this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
representative
so
have all members present and an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
161 on the affirmative 177 and the
negative the motion fails
the member from belmont representative
sylvia moves floor amendment 1246 which
can be found in your seat pockets and is
recognized to speak to his motion
thank you mr speaker
this amendment
does not take away from the underlying
bill
this is about
civil asset forfeiture which really is
a poorly described
term it's not civil at all
this is
a process of taking
property from citizens
without due process of law
this body has passed
this legislation
in the inventment
and
we should
ensure
that the other side of the wall gets the
message very loud and clear
with it being connected to this
bill
that we
are standing for the due process rights
of the citizens of this state
the federal government
has a program called
equitable sharing
is a mainly civil process where
assets
are taken through a process
in the federal court system
and
up to 80 percent of the
money that is forfeited in the civil
process without
the
protections that our state provides
eighty percent of that money is returned
to local departments
now there's two parts
to equitable sharing
there are joint task force operations
which this language does not touch
and then there are adoptions
our state law
since 2016
instituted a policy where
a criminal conviction was necessary
before
assets were
forfeited
and the proceeds
45 percent
returned to a local department 45
percent given to the department of
justice
and the remaining 10 percent
goes to
department of health and human services
there is a great incentive
for law enforcement
to go to the federal route
80 percent versus 45 percent
i can think of people describing and
i've never been to third world nations
where law enforcement
is put in a position where
they don't get paid through their
employment so much
but they make up a little
out on the road
we
should not
allow
our law enforcement
to be
incentivized
by this
process
of
gaining funds
which by the way
come back and they do not go through the
budgetary process
these funds go directly to the
department
whether it's your county sheriff's your
local police department
this money is off budget
this is not the way that we fund police
this is
an amendment which will support
good law enforcement it will support
due process rights and protections for
our citizens this is
language that has passed this body
several times
very strongly
and it's a message that needs to be
delivered across the wall loud and clear
so please
support this amendment
and let's get on with our day thank you
very much
the question is whether to adopt floor
amendments one two four six
representative umberger requests a
division vote this will be a division
vote members take your seats
so
elementary
oh
i also come to order
members should be in their seats this is
a division vote
representative sylvia is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that this amendment
does not take anything away
from the underlying bill
if i know that this amendment
adds due process rights
to the citizens
who may be caught up in a criminal
investigation
and i know
that we are going to serve the people of
the state better by passing this please
press the green button thanks
representative weiler is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
mr speaker
if i know this amendment is the same as
a bill that passed out of here on march
16th
and if i further know that we have told
the senate
we don't excuse the
the other body
that we don't like omnibus bills with
different subject matters
that what i now say this is unnecessary
since it's already the subject matter
this amendment is already in the other
body's hands when i now press the red
button so as to pass 1627 without
muddying it
thank you push the red button
the question is whether to adopt floor
amendment 1 2 4 6 h this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
representative shapiro
of all members presidents had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
78 having voted in the affirmative 247
and the negative the amendment fails
the member from merrimack representative
blasica's
moves floor amendment 1248 which is
found in your seat pockets and is
recognized to speak to a motion
thank you mr speaker
uh two weeks ago this body passed hb
1022 making ivermectin available via a
standing order and i think that that
bill is so important and historic that
we should amend it on to hv1627
i'll briefly discuss the most recent
jama study that concluded that
ivormectin did not work against covid19
besides the fact that this study treated
only already critically ill patients and
ivermectin was not used as early
treatment which is when proponents feel
it is most beneficial the actual data
from the study showed a very different
picture than the conclusion statement
in fact the conclusion is rather
laughable when you read the data from
the study
the ivermectin study was split into two
groups the vaccinated and the
unvaccinated
in the control arm of the study there
was only a 24 reduction in death from
vaccination alone but in the ivermectin
arm of the study there was a 72
reduction in death from in the
unvaccinated and a 67 reduction in death
in the vaccinated
but we've discussed covid and ivermectin
at nauseum so let's move on shall we
i did a brief search on the nih.gov
website for ivermectin and cancer
research
from a paper published january 2021
titled ivermectin a potential
anti-cancer drug derived from an
anti-parasitic drug quote ivermectin has
powerful anti-tumor effects including
the inhibition and of proliferation
metastasis and anti-genetic
activity in a variety of cancer cells
august 2021 in a paper titled ivermectin
has a new application in inhibiting
cororectal cancer cell growth quote
ivermectin an anti-parasitic drug has
been shown to possess anti-inflamma
anti-inflammation anti-viral and
anti-tumor tumor properties
february 2018 in a paper titled the
multi-targeted drug ivermectin from an
anti-parasitic agent to a repositioned
cancer drug quote ivermectin an
antiparasitic compound of wide use is
clearly a strong candidate for
repositioning based on the fact that one
it is very safe causing almost no side
effects and two it has proven anti-tumor
effects in pre-clinical studies i could
go on from there but i'll stop it's
clear however
that there is a plenty of evidence to
take ivermectin out of the anti-parasite
only box and be by being a cheap generic
drug there is little profit in doing so
with the politicization of this drug and
the general topsy-turvy world in which
we currently live where a fully fda
approved drug is practically impossible
to get in this state for any off-label
use despite the fact that normally
off-label prescribing is common practice
it is important we make sure our
colleagues on the other side of the wall
understand how vital it is to make this
safe and effective drug available to the
people of new hampshire i ask that you
press the green button so that we can
send that message
the question is on floor amendment one
two four eight h representative umberger
requests a division vote this will be a
division vote members please take your
seats
um
okay
the house will come to order
members should find their seats
the question is on amendment one two
four eight h
representative blasek is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry thank you mr
speaker mr speaker if i know that this
bill doesn't take away anything from the
underlying bill and if i know that we
need to send a clear message to the
other body about this life-saving drug
when i now broke vote green
representative umberger is recognized
for parliamentary inquiry
and members should be in their seats
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if you know everybody laughed
at my last parliamentary inquiry and i'm
not sure that i can
rise up to that again
however
what i can tell you
is
if i know i'm sorry if i know
that the only people doing the speaking
are the ones whose bills have already
passed
and that's why i'm having to do pis
and
just to tell you
there are three more speakers on the
amendments
and pis
and i will keep mine short
please
vote red
the question is on floor amendment
whether to adopt amendment 1248h if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
for 30 seconds
so
represent bergeron
representative bergeron thank you
representative newman's
thank you
have all members presidents had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
95 having voted in the affirmative 235
in the negative the amendment fails
for what reason does a member rise to
make a motion please state your motion
i moved to lay 1627 on the table
representative spelaine moves
that house bill 1627 be laid on the
table representative blasek requests a
roll call vote is that sufficiently
seconded
that's sufficiently seconded this will
be a redo roll call vote
so
oh
i also come to order the question is
whether to lay house bill 1627 on the
table representative spelaine is
recognized for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker if i know that we've
come real close to the end of the
calendar but yet we have a never-ending
pile of amendments for this bill in
front of us
would i now vote green to table 1627 and
move along with the day
the house will be in order
representative umberg is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
you mr speaker
once again
if i know
it's not me
that's taking up all this time
it would be if
it would really be wonderful
if those amendments that are still on
the calendar were
withdrawn
and then
we could go forward
with the final bill
and i would ask you to please vote red
once again
the question is whether to lay house
bill 1627 on the table this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
stations are open for 30 seconds
represent bradley
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
152 in the affirmative 181 in the
negative the motion fails again
the member from hudson representative
prout offers amendment
1252h which can be found in your seat
pockets and is recognized to speak to
his motion
and before everybody takes off i don't
think this is going to take very long
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker this amendment would attach
the state of emergency reform bill that
we passed in january to this bill
this state of emergency reform was a
critical piece of the agreements that
got us to a place where the budget would
pass last year
it differs from what was in hb2 last
year and is
now current law in that the default
thing that happens if nobody does
anything is
nothing
the state of emergency ends
under the current law the governor is
required to call this legislature into
special session to determine if the
state of emergency should end
however he does not have that authority
alone he must receive the approval of
the executive council to call us in a
special session
so what happens if the council
disapproves
the bill does not specify
and the state of emergency continues and
continues
and continues
gridlock it's often used as a negative
term but it's a critical feature of our
system of government multiple branches
of bodies of governments must agree
to change the status quo
the new hampshire constitution uses the
phrase have a negative on one another
but it's the same thing
and voters seem to know understand and
sometimes it looks like they preferred
we often seen the voters of this country
seemingly intentionally split the
branches and bodies of the federal
government among the parties and caused
this form of gridlock
why would that
be i think back to the phrase no man's
life liberty or property are safe while
the legislature is in session
we'll add my own extension unless it's
gridlocked
and so that's an important difference in
how these methods of dealing with a long
lasting state of emergency differ what
happens when there's gridlock
what happens when the branches of
government disagree
i argue that the most people would
assume that we can't agree the
government does nothing new or special
like the state of emergency
just like when we can't pass a law due
to gridlock
this isn't a referendum on how emergency
powers were used in the past this isn't
a retroactive law
nor is it meant to reflect on anyone
currently or holding or running for
office we went through 18 years after
the state of emergency reform in 2002
before it was used in a major way
i hope we go another 18 years or more
before
it's used again
but having a law in our books where four
individuals the governor and three
executive counselors
can definitely wield near complete
authority through a state of emergency
failing to call special special and
special session and possibly even
programming the legislature is not right
for new hampshire
i ask you to press the green button and
send the message that this reform is
important
that we expected it to be passed already
and that we're going to keep passing it
thank you mr speaker
the question is whether to adopt
amendment 1252-h
representative umberger requests a
division vote this will be a division
vote members please take your seats
i guess i could start now right
foreign
the question is whether to adopt
amendment 1252
h
representative pratt's recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
and he waves off
representative umberger is recognized
for parliamentary inquiry
uh thank you mr speaker
if i know you're getting very tired of
seeing me up here
that i would ask you to please press the
red button so we can get through this
quickly thank you
the question is whether to adopt
amendment 1252h this is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the red
button if you're opposed if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
89 in the affirmative 241 in the
negative the amendment fails
the member from barnstead representative
control moves
amendment
nine 1259h and is recognized to speak to
a motion
mr speaker may make a motion please
state your motion motion table
sorry representative contrast was
already recognized
perfect
the question is on amendment one two
five nine h representative umberger
requests a division vote this will be a
division vote members should take their
seats
representative pratt requests a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
roll call vote
so
you did what you're going to do
the question is whether to adopt
amendment 1259 h
representative contrast is recognized
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
if i know that hb 629 passed this house
in january with a veto proof majority
and mr speaker if i know that this bill
with overwhelming bipartisan support is
what the people of this great state want
and mr speaker if i know that this
homegrown bill
keeps the state
out of the drug dealing business
and mr speaker if i know that this bill
was sent to the other side and has not
yet had a vote
would i now press the green button
and send a strong message
and support the floor amendment
2022-1259-h
thank you mr speaker
representative lang is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know that this
amendment is house bill 629 which is
going to be heard in the other body on
april 7th at 9 00 am and you can all go
and testify to it the level 400 people
there
mr speaker if i know that this off
unneeded amendment makes the bill into a
christmas tree an omnibus bill and mr
speaker if i further know that last year
i spoke to many members who opposed the
christmas tree and omnibus bills and
vowed to vote against them when they
came over from the other body
mr speaker knowing all of this would i
now
expect those members who vowed to vote
against omnibus bills to push the red
button defeat this amendment so we can
move on and get to the bill as amended
from the committee
the question is whether to adopt
amendment 1259h
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
so
[Music]
of all members president had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
76 in the affirmative 258 in the
negative the amendment fails
the member from laconia representative
johnson moves floor amendments 1-2-8-2
and is recognized to speak to a motion
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
i move amendment 1282 and wish to speak
to my motion
this amendment would attach the
congressional redistricting plan to this
bill
this plan survived
and passed this body after a tabling
motion and was
nearly defeated by one vote
but its passage into law now looks
unlikely
not only
that it is unfair to all the individuals
running for these offices in either
district to have their campaigns upended
as they have been
by uncertain surroundings
what the district lines will be
unnecessarily uncertainty
unexpected uncertainty
it is unnecessary and unexpected because
we currently have a single party
political party
in our control in this state
everyone except us
who work together as a family to get
this done
everyone except those who use the house
proposed past
they could stop making
campaign plans and base it on
that everyone has
participated in the discussion and hash
things out behind the scenes
but that's not what happened
like we've always seen
with so far too many other bills
there is a
distinct lack of encouragement at the
public hearings
and any other communications until the
last minute
[Music]
if at all from the executive branch
and this house is just left to look
foolish passing things that won't be
signed into law
creating more work
and we work for all of us
we should start sending a clear message
that we're tired of that
these are the districts we passed
although thorough and thoughtful
considered
and you're going to see them attached to
quite a few things
maybe important things
i ask that you press the green button
and send a message that enough is enough
this is the way
of doing business
thank you mr speaker does the member
yield for a question
yes i will take one question
baltosari may inquire thank you mr
speaker uh thank you representative
taking my question you know we've been
sitting here to all these amendments
which you know i'm kind of shocked at
and my question to you is
did all these amendments come forward
because we wasted all this time on
amendment that we already passed that
does not even take effect of 2025 is
that what this is all about trying to
stop that amendment on something that
doesn't take effect at all
no
the member from hudson representative
proutz recognized to speak and support
the amendment
thank you mr speaker
i agree with the previous speaker and
i've seen it in my own town as it's been
in the various plans have been published
flip-flopping between the districts
going from evaluating candidates in one
district doing endorsements planning
house parties to now all of a sudden i
have to switch gears and look at the
other one
the back and forth
has been terrible for the politics in my
town
and terrible for planning for how to
support the great candidates that we
have running
and i ask you to vote green on this
amendment
to send the message that that was not
what we wanted
thank you does the member yield for a
question
yes
representative kelly a man choir
thank you thank you for taking the
question
i've heard some talk about omnibus bills
and uh with the adoption of the previous
amendment that was non-germane is this
bill already an omnibus bill and so
therefore if you're planning on
supporting it you can support all of
these other amendments also
thank you for the question i would say
the bill as it says before us uh as
amended by the first amendment does
contain more than one subject which is
most people's definition of an omnisore
spill
the member from goffstown representative
griffin is recognized to speak against
the amendment
thank you mr speaker
i am all for sending a clear message
i'm all for
that haven't had an opportunity to work
with all of you but those of you who
have worked with me
knows yes means yes
and no means no
and you don't need to ask
again pressing the red button means no
pressing the green button means yes
and i'm not going to send the bill to
you again
i have every confidence
that every member of this body who has
worked with me is capable of
understanding me when i say i'm for
something
and i have every confidence that the
other body is capable of understanding
that message when it comes over
and that is part of what we do
we are not here alone not alone in a
seat of of one in a room of 400 and not
alone in the legislative body
in regards to what we're talking about
i heard issues in regards to
redistricting well welcome to politics
every 10 years we redistrict and it's
not just new hampshire it's every state
in the union
and those districts change and they're
not your district
we don't start from incumbency
we start with census data and go forward
and we may not all agree on how to get
there and we may not agree on the
timetable and we may have a late
timetable but it's not news
because the secretary of state's office
has a process for changing the filing
period because it often happens that
redistricting affects the time period to
file for a district because we don't
have a final district
in regards to what you're being asked to
vote on today i have been placed in a
very difficult position
because i really like this bill
i really like the bill that this
amendment represents which is hb 52
which came out of the special committee
on redistricting and i voted for yes is
yes
the senate has voted excuse me the body
on the other side of the wall is voted
yes and is yes but we're here sending a
message because there are other messages
floating around in the political world
and i've already moved on to the next
step i don't know about you but i think
i might know what's coming and i think i
might have to come back to this body
with another cd map because the process
has not ended yet
and the sad thing is is that this
process today for addressing bills could
have been much further down the path
without multiple amendments creating
indeed an omnibus bill
when we are not capable of tabling any
of these amendments without
in fact tabling the underlying
legislation which many of us apparently
thought was good because it already
passed once
so as i've sat here today looking around
going through this and by the way how
many of you agree with me that the
sconces on this wall are 55 as compared
to the sidewall or 52.
i don't know i can never get the same
number the second time my eyes just
can't hold it
that's about as relevant to the
underlying bill as this amendment
so i stand here and i apologize for
taking up your time
and i i apologize
i wish i could apologize for others in
regards to taking up your time
so i want to just thank you for having
the courtesy of listening to me
and i ask
that you vote red
on the amendment that's presently before
you thank you
[Applause]
the question is whether to adopt
amendment 1282h
representative umberger request a
division vote this will be a division
vote members please take your seats
the question is whether to adopt
amendment 1282h this is a division vote
representative johnson's recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
waved off okay
representative hamburger
i'm sorry griffin waved off
awesome
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you'll press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
representative testerman
have all members president an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
60 having voted in the affirmative 270
and the negative the amendment fails
the question now is on the majority
committee report of octopass as amended
the member from hudson representative
prout is recognized to speak
waived off okay
the member from manchester
representative heath what's say you
perfect
the question is on the committee report
of ought to pass as amended are you
ready for the question
roll call representative sylvia
requested roll calls that's sufficiently
seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
mr
the questions on the majority committee
report about to pass as amended in house
bill 1627
this is a roll call vote
representative umberger is recognized
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
i want to thank all of you for your
indulgence
in getting through these amendments
and if i know
that it only makes sense
that we now pass
the bill as amended by pressing the
green button thank you
the questions on the majority committee
report about to pass as amended this is
a roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
opposed you'll press the red button
voting stations are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
have all members presence had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend to the state of
the vote
204 on the affirmative 131 and the
negative the committee report is adopted
the committee on finance to which was
referred house bill 1642
fn
an act relative to lead testing in
children having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolve that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
jess edwards for the committee the
questions on the committee report of
inexpedient to legislate are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
reports adopted
the majority of the committee on finance
which was referred house bill 1647 fn an
act relative to the calculation of child
support having considered the same
report the same with the following
amendment and the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass with amendment
representative just edwards for the
majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority report with the
recommendation that the bill be referred
for interim study representative mary
jane walner for the minority of the
committee
for what reason does it memorize
thank you mr speaker i moved to table
1647 fn
representative altschuler moves that
house bill 1647 be laid on the table are
you ready for the question
a division has been requested this will
be a division vote members take your
seats
representative barry requests a roll
call and it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
still please take your seats
yes
the
questions whether to lay house bill 1647
on the table
representative walner is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that the finance committee
could not determine the financial impact
of this bill
and if i know that the department of
health and human services is preparing a
report that will be available later this
year to help us understand the financial
impact of this piece of legislation
and if i know that is the responsibility
of the finance committee to evaluate the
financial impact of legislation and in
this case the committee was unable to do
our job
would i now vote yes to table this bill
representative edwards is recognized for
parliamentary inquiry uh thank you mr
speaker
if i knew that
[Music]
upon listening to the minority of the
committee that we adopted an amendment
to do as they asked which was to cut out
the portion of the bill dealing
with that would have had the financial
impact to take that issue off the table
and if i know
that the remaining part of it is an
essential element that the courts have
been begging for since 2018
which is a formula that would help
establish fairness
whenever there's a shared parenting
agreement
and if i knew
that family court is hell
and we could make it a little less bad
if we put this formula in place would i
now
vote against this tabling
motion with the red button so that we
can hear the debate
thank you
the question is whether to lay house
bill 1647 on the table this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
representative gratia thank you
representative simon
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote
the house will attend the state of the
vote
155 and the affirmative 179 and negative
the motion fails
the question is now on the committee
amendment 1171 h printed in house record
12 on page 38.
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted
the question is now on the majority
committee report about to pass with
amendment the member from concord
representative walner is recognized to
speak against the committee report
thank you mr speaker
house bill
1647 is exactly the kind of bill that
should come to the finance committee as
a second committee
the policy committee and the house
passed new policy that has potential for
financial impact on the state budget
during division three work sessions on
this bill there was testimony on the
policy for members of the public
but the department of health and human
services could not give us information
on the financial impact of this
legislation
the department
representatives informed us
that they are now working on a report
which will provide us with information
that will be helpful in determining the
financial impact of this policy change
this bill should not move forward until
we understand the impact it will have on
our tanf
food stamp medicaid and housing
assistance expenditures
the job of the finance committee is to
figure out the cost of new policy
more time and information are needed
before we have adequate information to
pass this legislation
i urge members to vote no on this motion
and to allow for a
motion of
interim study the motion to come in
interim study to come forward thank you
the member from where representative
earth is recognized to speak in support
of the committee report
thank you mr speaker
a number of study committees over the
past few years
have looked at our child support laws in
2015 the legislature authorized half
million dollars to this to the carsey
school for the most extensive study to
review new hampshire's child support
guidelines
their report was complete in 2018
and stated quote
as substantially equal parenting
increases in a number of cases
a larger proportion
of child support cases
must deviate from the guidelines to
account for the sharing of expenses
this results in a range of possible
outcomes
little predictability for parents
entering the system
and in some cases
judgments that are inconsistent
and not fair alternately
to the obligate
or obligor quote
i don't know what those are either but
it's basically one side of the other
in 2018 the courts made it difficult
under current law
to provide for shared child support
when shared parenting is approved
in the most extreme case
this means that if one parent
has one dollar more of income
than the other
and the parenting is being shared 50 50
all of the child support goes to the
parent with one dollar less income
the parent with one dollar more income
pays the other parent
their half of the child support
leaving them without the funds to
support the child who was with them half
the time
the amendment we passed
changes the income threshold
below which
a person qualifies to make a fixed
contribution
of fifty dollars per month
to child support
from one hundred and fifty percent of
the federal poverty level
back to a hundred and fifteen percent as
in current law
this minimizes the fiscal impact to the
state of new hampshire
during the transition to the more fairly
balanced child support allocations
the next legislature
will then have the quadrennial review
of the child support system
being done by the new hampshire
department of health and human services
that will be completed in december
to work with in making further
improvements to the system
the bill as prepared by the policy
committee
and passed by this house on a voice vote
addresses the recommendation of the car
seat school
for a better formula for shared
parenting
please join me in supporting this bill
thank you mr speaker
the questions on the majority committee
report have ought to pass with amendment
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
all those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
reports adopted
speakers
committee on finance to which was
referred house bill
1661 fn local also be in order
an act relative to regional career
career technical education agreements
having considered the same
report the same with the following
amendment the recommendation of the bill
auto password amendment president of
kate murray for the committee the
amendment is
1173h
printed in house record 12 page 38.
the debate is on the amendment
the chair recognizes representative
andrews to speak against the committee
report
amendment against the amendment
thank you mr speaker
i am not against a legislative packing
garage appropriation
next year
but i am against amendment 2022
1173 h
appropriating 35 million dollars this
year
as for the proposal for a new parking
garage
there are many unanswered questions that
each of us should be asking
the current suggested location at 33
capital street
for a new parking garage
are there any other viable alternatives
do we really want to
vote
to destroy
the building which now houses the
department of justice
this building was built back in the
1950s for the new hampshire savings bank
and later many years later the state
purchased the property as the fdic
wanted to sell
it's 35 million a feasible amount for
demolishing
the stores street garage
finding a new location and moving the
department of justice
and then
demolishing the building at 333 capitol
street
and build a new parking garage
i understand a project usually goes
through the house public works and
highways committee
but we did not go through this process
in 2018 quantum construction consultants
was hired to inspect the store street
garage
an estimate for repairs
was
1.9 million and there was a capital
budget request for the st for the store
street garage
we have spent much money on repairs
even recently
what is the projected lifespan of the
store street garage
i think is something each of us needs to
know
is it one month or one year
two months or two years
i watched and listened
very carefully to the finance committee
hearing
ideal in detailed
figures
and all we have is totals i asked
requested details of the 35 million of
how it's going to be spent and as of
today i had not received it
i need this kind of information to make
a sound decision to spend 35 million
dollars
i know a new garage will have to be
built
but i believe the time is not here and
is not now
we are in double-digit inflation
many citizens in new hampshire
are trying to figure out how to pay
their gas bills for the vehicle to get
back and forth to work
how to pay the food bill with the rising
costs
how to pay for their mortgage or rent
and electricity and heating bills
i would like to hope
inflation is going to lessen
but currently do not believe it
if we are going
to have
35 million dollars plus surplus
then why don't we make plans
to give much of it back to the citizens
of new hampshire
and utilize the remainder of the surplus
to possibly pay down some of new
hampshire's debts
i represent the citizens of new
hampshire and i ask you to vote now on
this amendment let's help our citizens
next year
the house public works and highway
committee
can work on viable areas and costs for a
new parking garage thank you
chair recognized representative murray
thank you mr speaker
we heard this week of a parking garage
that collapsed in boston
the old garage was in the process of
being demolished
thank you
was in process of being demolished as it
had exceeded its expected life span
something happened the garage came down
a worker was killed
we're facing a similar situation with
the storage street garage which has
exceeded its lifespan but is still
standing
at least for now
this amendment addresses this problem
the current garage is in a state of
serious disrepair
for years there have been discussions
regarding the parking garage and the
need to replace replacement
but the can has always been kicked down
the road
today we've reached the end of the road
and action is required now
those of us who park there have noticed
netting
really heavy netting that hangs below
the first and second floor decks
the netting is there to keep chunks of
the garage from falling onto the street
or falling onto the floor the first
floor deck or onto cars
or onto people
i've been watching that netting very
carefully since this was brought to my
attention and i try to drive a little
faster to get to the second floor level
although the really tight turns still
slow me down
further there's been an increasing
number of reports of injuries
to date at least these injuries have
been relatively minor
they involve scrapes and cuts from the
railings trips and stumbles because of
the uneven surfaces as i said the number
of reports is increasing and we need to
address this problem before it becomes
more numerous
as well as more serious
some of you may have not realized as a
speaker said before that we have been
spending several million dollars
for some years now in order to keep the
garage usable and at some level safe
i have to add
that there seems to be various levels of
understanding as to what is safe
sort of safe
or just plain unsafe
however you see it the millions are
adding up quickly and are not doing
anything to address the problem
for these reasons this situation has
reached the point where it must be
considered an emergency and this
amendment
the amendment will lodge 35 million
dollars to do four tasks one is to
demolish the current garage
two is to demolish the building now home
to the department of justice
three is to relocate the department of
justice to a new location one already
available and four to construct a new
garage on the site of the current
location
let me add that many consider the
current location of the department of
justice to be somewhat unsuitable for
the sensitive work that they do
this new garage will also solve another
problem with stores in that it does not
have enough spaces for all the
legislators who are assigned to park
there
you're on your own to find your own
parking if you're a tad late for session
the new structure will have enough space
for all and it will provide far better
access
for those with disabilities
the new project will not be bonded but
will use cash that is currently on hand
by not bonding the project there will be
no adverse effect on projects supported
throughout the capital projects process
it always stings when we have to spend
money and 35 million dollars is a lot of
money
for some there are always going to be
other projects that would seem to be
more critical for others spending money
on anything stings
regardless this is a problem that
requires our attention now
at this time i don't have the details
regarding the design i don't have a
timeline i'm asking support of this
amendment in order to finally get this
long overdue process underway
we do need to address this emergency
before the situation becomes
catastrophic which will be far more
expensive not only financially but also
on a human level i ask you please
support this amendment thank you for
your attention
the motion before us
is
the amendment 1173h
representative dodge has requested a
roll call is not sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote members take your seats
just
so
the house will be in order
the motion before us is on the amendment
this is a roll call vote chair
recognizes representative umberger for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know
that store street garage
needs replacing
yesterday
or maybe five years ago
but
if i know that it has always been put
off
because we have had higher priorities
and if i know
the dollars are available
this year
that we can finally
make progress
on getting the store street garage built
would you please press the green button
thank you
the motion before us
is on
how on amendment 1173h
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're opposed you will press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
so
[Music]
house will be in order
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend to the state of the
vote
271 voting a 65 voting a
committee amendment is adopted
the motion before us now
is the motion of ought to pass with
amendment
on house bill 1661.
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted
committee on finance to which was
referred house bill 1662
fn
an act related to privacy obligations of
the department of health and human
services i consider the same report the
same with the following amendment the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass for the amendment of jess edwards
for the committee the amendment is one
one three four h
printed in house record 12 pages 38-39
the question is on the amendment are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee the
amendment is adopted the motion before
us now is ought to pass with amendment
on
1662 fn are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it the committee report is
adopted
no
committee on finance to which was
referred house bill 1682-fna
an act establishing the law enforcement
conduct review committee in new
hampshire police standards and training
council and making an appropriation
therefore having considered the same
report the same with the following
amendment the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass with amendment
senator bob lynn for the committee the
amendment is 1099
printed in house record 12
page 39. the question is on the
amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it the committee amendment
is adopted the question before us now
is the ought to pass with amendment
motion on 1682
fna are you ready for the question all
those in favor say aye
those are palestine
the eyes have it the committee report is
adopted
committee on ways and means to which was
referred house bill 1584 fn an act
establishing a capital improvement grant
program for the benefit of state fairs
and agricultural fears considered the
same report the same with the following
amendment the recommendation to build
out a password amendment of judy aaron
for the committee the amendment is one
one five six h printed in house record
12 pages 24 through 26.
the question is on the amendment are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the amendment is
adopted the motion before us now is
ought to pass with amendment on house
bill 1584 rfn are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted
also be in order
majority of the committee on ways and
means to which was referred house bill
fn an act legalizing
the possession and use of cannabis
having considered the same report the
same with the following amendment the
recommendation bill ought to pass with
amendment presenter timothy lang for the
majority of the committee
minority of the committee
have been considered the same being
unable to agree with the majority report
the recommendation that the bill be
referred for interim study
representative richard ames the minority
of the committee
majority committee report is 1172h
printed in house record 12
page 27. the question is on the majority
amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it the majority amendment
is
adopted
bill is open to second reading a further
amendment
and we're looking at floor amendment
1 9 8 h by representative major
and who is recognized to speak to his
amendment
thank you mr speaker
this support amendment
is a simple amendment it clarifies how
the 50
of the net profit from the sale of
cannabis
is used in setting the education tax
rate
rsa 676 colon 3
is clarified by this amendment to say
that 363 million dollars used in setting
the statewide education property tax
rate is reduced by the amount credited
to the education trust fund
pursuant to
rsa 318 f 8 15 which you just passed in
the amendment
thank you
the question before
the house
is the major floor amendment 1198h
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and a major floor
amendment is adopted
further
bill's open the second reading and
further amendment
the chair recognizes
yes
the chair recognizes representative
marsh
to offer floor amendment 1-2-3-0-h
and the chair recognizes representative
marsh
thank you mr speaker
this too is another simple amendment
and i rise in support of floor amendment
one two three
zero h in your seat pockets last year we
passed house bill
by a 255 to 101 vote
that bill directed
dhhs in public health to create posters
and make information available at the
dispensaries regarding the use of
cannabis when pregnant
or when lactating about accidental
poisonings and about its use during
adolescence
we did this because u.s surgeon general
jerome adams had expressed his concern
about these uses
and he wanted us to address the subject
this floor amendment simply extends the
same requirement which already exists at
the atcs to retail cannabis stores
the posters and the informational
material already exist
i urge you to vote in favor of this
thank you
the question before us is the marsh
floor amendment
1230h
are you ready for the question
all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay
[Applause]
a division a division has been requested
only members in the room nobody can come
in
members need to return to your seats
just a moment ago
no
the house will be in order
the motion before it is the marsh floor
amendment 1-2-3-0-h
this is a clarifying vote this is a
division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations are
open for 30 seconds
represented
house will be in order members be need
to be in their seats
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote
house will attend the state of the vote
212 voting a 89 voting a
the march 4 amendment is adopted
bills on second reading opened a further
amendment
representative connolly order offers
floor amendment 1283h
and his recognizer speaker
i i recognize you representative
connolly thank you mr speaker i
appreciate that
colleagues
four amendment uh one two five three h
is a friendly amendment that fixes an
unintended consequence
from the committee majority amendment
that we just passed
under that amendment edible cannabis
products can no longer be sold in retail
establishments
but the amendment also eliminated the
existing cannabis decriminalization
statute
the bill does that because if we're
legalizing it we no longer need a
decriminalization statute anymore
but by removing retail sale of edible
cannabis products from the bill and
striking the decrim statute it puts
edible cannabis in a legal limbo
this amendment fixes it
it restores the personal possession
limit for cannabis infused products at
300 milligrams of thc for adults 21 and
older that's the exact same standard
that already exists under
decriminalization
so again this is a fix
no more no less and i ask you to pass it
thank you
the motion before us is the conley floor
amendment one two eight three h are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
the eyes have it and the
floor conley floor amendment is adopted
bills on second reading opened a further
amendment
chair the representative abramsmen's
office floor amendment
i don't have a number
the amendment is one two eight six h
and it is in your seat pockets
the chair recognizes representative
abramson
noah abramson
all right sorry about that i heard abbas
thank you mr speaker this is my only
long speech of the session all my all my
speeches are usually about 30 seconds so
if members have to take a bathroom break
this will be the time
um
i move uh
amendment 1286h
in your seat pockets it looks long
but
it's it's
about as simple as you can imagine the
member will suspend
the house is getting awful noisy the
member has a right to be heard the house
will be in order
if you need to have a conversation take
it out into the annie room remember we
may continue
the
the amendment is about as simple as you
can imagine instead of having
the liquor commission set up a number of
state-run liquor stores around sorry a
number of state-run
marijuana stores around the state it
would just have private business
sell it and dispensaries sell it in
towns where the voters had approved the
sale of cannabis
amendment 1286h would simply remove from
this bill the requirement that the
liquor commission buy sell inventory and
advertise marijuana instead of just
letting private sellers and existing
dispensaries sell cannabis
this would still be under the regulation
and oversight of the liquor commission
and there are no other major policy
changes under the law
other than medical marijuana all
cannabis products under this amendment
would simply
be subject to the 8.5 percent meals and
rooms tax
generating an estimated 44 million
dollars a year according to the tax
foundation
in addition
uh following these sales
sales estimates state municipal
governments would bring in an estimated
20 to 30 million dollars in additional
business and property taxes without
having the state
take a huge risk on another state-run
enterprise compare that with the rosie
estimates in the majority report
of 30 million dollars a year if this new
state-run monopoly doesn't end up like
every other state-run monopoly
by the way every hypothetical dollar
of revenue in this in
the uh criminal justice version of the
bill is earmarked in the bill
uh plus tens of millions more
so that there
really couldn't be any possible way that
i can see that there'd be revenue left
for the general fund
but let me be absolutely clear this
amendment simply would have private
establishments taking all of the risks
to have them buy sell an inventory
cannabis rather than one top heavy
state-run monopoly
doing the work without this amendment
the state would have to expend
according to the fiscal note
up front 7.9 million dollars plus
another nine million dollars a year in
operating costs
then proposes to transfer hypothetical
profits of 25 million dollars to dhhs
and millions more to state agencies
on a perishable inventory estimated at
seven hundred thousand dollars
i cannot understand any business model
that could work out this way nor
understand
why any republican would vote for
something that runs completely contrary
to the spirit and letter of the new
hampshire gop platform and everything
that we stand for
with without this amendment
the bill simply proposes to trade one
failed soviet era policy mass
incarceration with another
soviet agriculture
who's going to stand in or soviet
grocery stores i should say who's going
to stand in line two hours waiting for
weed
no one if you can drive 20 minutes to
the next state since
cannabis is is legal to buy in almost
every other part of the northeast mr
speaker if someone came to you with this
business plan asking for tens of
millions of dollars for a completely
untested and unfeasible business model
with no realistic way to turn a profit
on just seven hundred thousand dollars
in perishable inventory unlike the
state-run liquor stores
would you write them a check for over 18
million dollars
not on your salary you wouldn't
well i only make 22 cents an hour in
this position
and if i were a
venture capitalist who approved this
business plan in the private sector i
would find myself making zero cents an
hour because i would be fired
but let's just imagine
that every socialist activist in new
england came to new hampshire's stoner
palace to finally see soviet-style
socialism working for the first time
ever in history after seeing new
hampshire spend over 1 million dollars a
year on advertising according to the
fiscal note coming straight from the
liquor commission
suppose these trotskyites love new
hampshire socialism so much that they
decide to settle down here and get all
their friends
sorry get all their friends to buy from
stoners palace i cannot see any
realistic way that a state-run monopoly
could possibly compete with hundreds
of rapidly evolving innovative cannabis
sellers in the northeast and thousands
of e-commerce
sites all over the country
in my two decades living in the live
free or die state i have seen many bills
both as a member and as a private
citizen attempting to create state-run
banks commuter rail and other state-run
enterprises
and they have all been defeated here
because there is no public support for
that brand of socialism even from the
hardened
socialist activists the state-run liquor
stores are the first thing that
left-wing activists
complain to me
when they move here without amendment
we'd be setting a dangerous precedent
that private business will now be
replaced with state-run monopolies by
whomever future government governors
appoint without our input and without
our say-so
consider the track record of cost of
other state-run monopolies
twenty years ago when i moved here
people complained that public schools
were charging seven thousand dollars a
year per student now it's almost twenty
thousand the prison system was costing
nine thousand dollars per year per
inmate now it's nearly sixty thousand
under the bill it estimates fifty six
thousand
when they get out it costs over sixty
one thousand per year to put them on
welfare in section 8 because they can't
get a job with a modern diploma and a
criminal record many of them for being
prosecuted for marijuana
convictions every person i saw at the
public hearing and ways and means
and everyone who signed the blue sheet
on the criminal
justice committee's version of this bill
was in opposition
banking commissioner banking association
police chiefs association every single
cannabis activist dispensary marijuana
policy project and medical marijuana
advocates
without this amendment
1286 the bill has zero public support
and every single post on citizens count
on social media opposed the idea of
getting the state to buy sell inventory
and advertise marijuana
multi-million dollar bureaucracies
created without public support
beget powerful political constituencies
that make future reforms and future
changes difficult or impossible for
example even though the state could make
two to three times we've been told
two to three times as much revenue by
re-privatizing the state-run liquor
stores and just putting an excise on
liquor
that can never happen now because no one
can take on that multi-million dollar
political juggernaut and the complex
system of rsas that has grown up around
the state-run liquor stores
and won't this state-run enterprise also
become political will decisions about
its operation be as practical as those
made by private business
if state-run liquor stores are the model
uh
sorry i probably shouldn't say that
hey i ran into trouble earlier so i'm
just going to delete that
no i'm not going to say it it's just
funny
if members think that a dozen marijuana
bills per session i'll say to tandy's
later
if members think that a dozen marijuana
bills per session eat up too much of our
time already imagine what will happen if
we have perhaps 30 plus bills a year
trying to have the state
state decide whether or not to have
stoners palace be open on easter sunday
highway placement how much to spend on
signs or
feel good programs or bureaucracy half
the bills introduced here
now deal with
the school system and prison
system will new hampshire cultivators
and distributors
now be forced to sell only to the state
as business owners warned
at the ways and means hearing
many worried that they would be put out
of business
will some be forced out of business
unable to sell outside of the state-run
monopoly will an out-of-state company
buy up those few cultivators and force
the state
to pay twice as much for perishable
cannabis leaves causing the liquor
commission to lose money every year the
residency requirement in the bill is
only for the initial license
not for continuation
and will the one million dollars a year
spent on advertising
marijuana try to send the message to
kids that they shouldn't buy drugs
but if they do try and buy them from the
state
actions speak louder than words and no
dare billboard will carry any weight
with teenagers if it stands right across
the street from another billboard
promoting drug use the criminal justice
committee recently rejected a similar
bill my bill
on the argument that business might
advertise glass pipes and scales
criminal justice can't have it both ways
state promotion of drug use at taxpayer
expense is perhaps the most unpopular
policy ever considered by the house yet
is still on the bill
many of my republican colleagues now
support re-legalization only as a tool
to reduce drug use not promoted at
taxpayer expense
we were told repeatedly by majority on
criminal justice to vote down other
marijuana bills because they had some
big compromise bill that they were
working on and this monstrosity and it
is a monstrosity
is it and it needs to be amended
the vote in ways and means was certainly
not unanimous it was 12 to 10.
with many of those who voted for it who
voted ought to pass with amendment
admitting both before and after the
hearing that they hate this version but
they felt that they couldn't change it
this bill
is the worst idea since congress spent
eight hundred fifty six thousand dollars
to find out how long it would take to
train lions to walk on a treadmill it
took eight months
it shouldn't take eight months to figure
out we need to hit the green cannabis
button on the amendment 1286
to remove the socialist big government
aspects of the bill and simply convert
it into a simple revenue bill
better to get 65 million dollars a year
with no risk to the state than maybe
gain
or lose 30 million dollars a year we
don't make changes
in the house because the senate might
want changes
we pass
sorry
those we do not speak of
we pass the house position and let those
we do not speak of propose their own
changes on the other side of the wall
when has the house ever caved into the
senate to senate demands or speculated
about senate positions
when has the house ever changed
legislation based on rumors about what
the senate might add
let senators speak for themselves press
the green button and help us downsize
government
a division has been
requested members will start taking your
seats we're down to the last speaker
chair recognizes representative avis
thank you mr speaker
i rise in opposition to
the
floor amendment 1286 1286h
i'm not going to take as much time to
respond to every single point that was
just made
but i heard it was the one of the points
was that it was the most unpopular
proposal of all time i just want to
point out we there was a division vote
on the first go round and it passed this
body by a vote of 235 yays to 119 nays
so it did pass once already
so i don't believe it's the most uh
least popular of all time
but
in addition to being a nine and a half
page floor amendment that has did not go
through any committee if you go to the
last page
you'll see where the rooms and meals tax
says nine percent
we uh i believe this body and it was
something that we took a lot of pride in
lowering the rooms and meals tax to
eight and a half percent
so this would be raising the rooms and
meals tax
unrelated to canvas
it would be increasing it back to nine
with that being said by having cannabis
be taxed under the rooms and meals tax
which
is neither a room nor a meal
you are essentially
starting to convert that
rooms and meals tax into a full-on
retail sales tax this is the beginning
it will start with this floor amendment
today
that's where it will begin because now
we have a retail product
that we are selling
in a retail store
calling it we're trying not to call it a
sales tax but it is a sales tax so
eventually your rooms and meals tax will
be a full-on retail sales tax that's
what this
amendment would actually
do
and for that reason
please
push that red button do not raise taxes
and don't support any type of sales tax
thank you mr speaker does a member yield
the questions
no
member does not yield
the motion before us is the abramson
floor amendment one two eight six h this
is a division vote members take your
seats
for what reason is member rise uh let me
ask you a question of the chair
state your questions
doesn't the last page of the bill say
quote eight and a half percent of the
charge of taxable meals sales of
cannabis cannabis accessories and so
forth
that's not a question of the chair all
right thank you
so
the house will come to order
the motion before us
is the abramson floor amendment 1286h
this is a division vote
the chair recognizes representative
accident for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that this amendment preserves
the great progress
this body has made in the last several
years
as it reduces the penalties for the use
and possession of the plant that we seek
to legalize
if i know that putting cannabis under
the meals and rooms tax would mean
revenue is estimated in the tens of
millions plus an extra 20 30 million in
business and property tax revenue
if i know that this amendment eases
concerns that members across the aisle
may have about a liquor commission
monopoly on cannabis
and if i know that i
like two-thirds of this body and 70
percent of the state of new hampshire
just want to finally get cannabis
legalized
would i now support this bipartisan
amendment thank you
jay i recognize representative lang for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker thank you
colleagues for listening
if i know mr speaker that this bill
while well-meaning provides no mechanism
to move the money from the rooms and
meals tax fund into the cannabis control
fund which is what will pay for the
operation of state stores and give your
towns the needed relief that are part of
the bill of the original amendment and
mr speaker if i further know
that
this bill as written is nothing more
than a gateway tax to a full-blown
retail sales tax
mr speaker right now press the red
button oppose this bill so we can get on
to the original bill as amended thank
you
the motion before us is the abramson
floor amendment one two eight six h this
is a division vote
if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you oppose you press the
red button voting stations are open for
30 seconds
so
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
the state of the vote
77 voting a 257 voting a the amendment
fails
for what reason does the member rise
mr speaker i rise to table 1598
that is a proper motion
motion motion before us is the table
house bill 1598 a division has been
requested
members take your seats
who requested the roll call
senator blazik requests a roll call is
that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
a roll call vote
no she is
the motion before us is the tabling
motion on house bill 1598
this is a roll call vote
chair recognizes representative muller
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that the ways and means
committee worked very hard to put
safeguards into 1598 but this bill has
not proven its fiscal solvency and is
not ready for prime time
and if i know that new hampshire has
already codified targeted solutions to
address medical marijuana and
decriminalization
but full legalization has proven harmful
to 18 other states
and if i know that nashua and manchester
already struggling with 110 percent
increase in drug overdoses this past
year alone and finally
if i know that during a recent
discussion on legalization our governor
was quoted as saying quote i have talked
to a lot of governors who said boy it
has been a real problem
would i now press the green button to
table 1598.
gee i recognize representative conley
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker if i know that this
bill has already passed this house by an
almost veto proof margin if i know that
this bill would raise millions of
dollars for property tax relief the
state retirement system and law
enforcement
and finally mr speaker if i know that
kicking the can down the road for
another year
does a disservice to the residents of
the state who just want us to get this
done
so i would ask you to press the red
button to defeat the tabling motion
thank you
the motion before us is the tabling
motion on house bill 1598. this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
to press the red button voting stations
are open for 30 seconds
[Music]
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend
the state of the vote
under an 18 voting yay
2016 voting a the tabling motion fails
now we're on to the bill has ought to
pass as amended
is
okay the questions on the majority
committee report about to pass with
amendment the member from seabrook
representative abramson is recognized to
speak against the committee report
i'm sorry is that isn't that in
opposition
thank you mr speaker now i really will
be brief
uh
i rise in opposition to
house bill 1598
as amended
and for one very simple reason as i
mentioned during my previous statements
that the rough estimate of total sales
by some outside groups would be about
400 to 500 million dollars a year
so that that's probably true but that
would be not only larger than the entire
prison industry would be many times
larger than the entire prison industry
and as the figures that i brought up
before that the cost per inmate has gone
from in my time in new hampshire has
gone from nine thousand dollars a year
per inmate to sixty thousand dollars a
year per inmate
this is six times more expensive in the
last twenty years the cost of government
goes up and up and up and up and up
if members have any thought of maybe one
day legalizing or coming up with any
other policy
this is absolutely this would be
absolutely the biggest most powerful
political constituency that we would
ever have to fight against to make any
kind of political change in the future
i'm asking you as every
single
activist every marijuana policy activist
the marijuana policy
group the dispensaries
a marijuana policy project all of them
asked they asked ways and means to vote
this down to stop this because they know
about the long-term the long-term
unintended consequences of going down
this path i don't know of any other
state that has done this with cannabis
we have seen this with other types of
state-run monopolies and
it it should never be we'll never have a
realistic chance to privatize this
once this gets deep rooted
please press the red button
the member from sugar hill
representative egan is recognized to
speak against the committee report
thank you mr speaker
i did come here with the intention to
speak against this bill but my friends
my colleagues i'm at a quandary
i'm not a fan of big government yes i'm
a democrat saying i'm not a fan of big
government surprise surprise
i'm not a fan of state-run monopolies
but i am a fan of listening to the 70 70
maybe 80 percent and growing
constituents in our state that ask
for us
to legalize cannabis
i've been very outspoken on both sides
of the aisle about my interest to
legalize cannabis
i say if not now then when
we need to send a message to the body on
the other side of the wall for them to
tell our constituents 75 80 percent of
them
that
they are not being heard
let the
body on the other side of the wall tell
people that 80 percent of them their
opinions do not matter
i ask you to vote in favor of house bill
1598 so that we can do the business that
the people of the state of new hampshire
sent us here to do which is to legalize
cannabis
create revenue for our state create
economic development
and begin to move on with other business
that this body has
thank you
does the member yield for a question
i do
representative warden you may inquire
thank you mr speaker and thank the
member for taking my question
is it your understanding would you agree
that this the type of state monopoly
proposed in this bill
has not been tried in the other 18
states that have legalized cannabis and
thus would be risky bureaucratic costly
and potentially turn this program into a
boon goggle boondoggle for the state of
new hampshire
thank you sir for the question
i do have an issue with that
most all not most all states in the
united states that have legalized
cannabis have a cannabis control
commission that allows them to have
oversight over the industry
one of my concerns with this bill is
that we do not have that
hopefully that's something that our
friends on the other side of the wall
can take up when we send them this bill
we do need to have
a clear
oversight of
regulation
separate from the folks that sell the
product that's what we've been doing
here in the united states for three
almost 300 years we have regulation over
sales
so there is a concern that i have that
was probably one of the main concerns
that i was not in favor of the state
oriented business model that has
this bill has been built on
but i think
again at the end of the day as i sat
here for the last
three hours thinking about what i was
going to say
i thought who sent me here it's the fine
people from sugar hill and franconia and
lisbon and lyman and monroe who are
farmers and hunters and hard-working
north country folks who have said to me
over and over and over again whether
they're bankers or farmers or educators
that
we're in favor of legalized cannabis we
look silly compared to maine and
massachusetts and now vermont and canada
and there are state-run stores in nova
scotia that we can look as a model
so at the end of the day what is my job
not to tell you
what i think and what i feel but to do
what the people voted me here to do
which is to represent their viewpoint
that 75 to 80 percent of them
want legalized cannabis
so thank you for your question sir
thank you mr speaker
the member from londonderry
representative baldassaro is recognized
to speak in support of the committee
report
thank you mr speaker
fellow representatives i was going to
stay silent on this here and because i i
could care i don't never smoke marijuana
in my life and i've had it all around me
many times i actually voted against
medical marijuana
but for the record mr speak i can tell
you that i do condone violence at the
oscars i wanted to put that out there by
the way
on my mind there because this could be
my last time speaking here at the well
a friend of mine who passed away uh
prior to losing his life the
distinguished minority leader from
hampton he fought for this marijuana for
many many years i won't you keep that in
mind when we do cast his vote
he he really did support this here
the marijuana bill we all talk about a
monopoly of monopoly monopoly you know
something for 15 years that's all i
heard the constitution says the monopoly
i hear people reps come and go in here
but you want to know something cable is
a monopoly
other areas here internet alcohol we
have monopolies all over let's cease the
bs on it's a monopoly enough is enough
now i'm going to tell you one thing
if you
let this die
and you're a big marijuana supporter
this is the nose under the tent
this is your opportunity to get the nose
under the tent get something past where
i'm here and i don't know how true it is
but i'm hearing somebody's gonna let it
go without a signature okay this is
election year you finally have an
opportunity to pass something
something
if you do not get this here going and
this does not pass this year
you get a governor who gets reelected
election time's over you know all the
game in this business
you'll never get it again it will be
vetoed and vetoed and vetoed
so you might as well make a tough
decision here today the house has voted
this in many times do i like the state
involved in this here hell no i don't
but you want to know something
you got no choice i either you want
marijuana you don't you can't have the
whole pie we have to take a little piece
at a time
later on you come back and you fix it
you get add more to it you do whatever
you got to do but you got to get the
nose under the tent and if you don't
then you failed
it's you're not never going to have it
i'm not going to lose sleep i'll be in
florida where it's passed i think but
so i recommend
that you really deep
think deep down inside your heart and
realize do i want it or do i not
do i care and listen to this garbage
about it's a monopoly when it's all over
new hampshire monopoly we're a small
state we do not have a tax revenue
if you want sales tax payroll tax and
vote this down
vote it down
eventually this state is going to run
out of other people's money this is
choice
money right that we got going on right
now
so if anything for the former minority
leader i would say this should be at
least over 300 or nothing or whatever we
got here thank you
chair recognizer representative connerk
speak against the committee report
thank you mr speaker
i'm also torn
because as many of you know i have
favored cannabis legalization for years
and i sponsored a bill to do so in the
past
my seat number
is 4-20.
and i was informed that that was not a
coincidence and now that i have your
attention we can carry on with the rest
of the information
so the bottom line is though i rise to
point out the negative impact of hb 1598
on the therapeutic cannabis program
in new hampshire i serve as the chair of
the therapeutic cannabis medical
oversight board
that board is charged with medical
oversight to the new hampshire
therapeutic cannabis program and this
year the board knowing that there are a
lot of various legalization bills coming
up
passed a resolution that stated quote
any bill legalizing cannabis for adult
use in new hampshire should be evaluated
to determine its impacts on the
therapeutic cannabis program
the therapeutic cannabis program is
valuable and must be preserved
if adult legalization passes
now
in the rest of my statement though i
will be speaking for myself
the board did not make a specific
recommendation on hb1598
as they did not have the opportunity to
go into the weeds on it
now that i really have your attention
i'll tell you the details about it the
issue is that
hb1598 will endanger the existence of
the therapeutic cannabis program
remember that the purpose of therapeutic
cannabis is really very different than
recreational cannabis
it's the alternative treatment center
spent a lot of time counseling patients
reviewing their medical condition their
previous treatments their previous
experience with cannabis and their
treatment goals
they have a robust education program for
their for their patients regarding risks
safety dosing roots of administration
the patient is then started at a low
dose and under supervision is titrated
slowly upward to reach the desired
therapeutic effect
without the unwanted effect
of intoxication
as a result the atcs also have to stock
a really broad range of products
oriented to the medical population in
particular
non-intoxicating strains of cannabis
with varying concentrations of thc and
cbd along with different delivery
methods such as topicals and
suppositories which you don't find in a
recreational store to meet the needs of
different patients
high potency products are going to be
available for certain patients in
certain conditions
now all of these factors will create
unique costs for the atc which will not
be faced by their recreational stores
okay minor problem except then when you
combine that with a lack of taxation
and the
intention of rock bottom prices to
undercut the regional price of cannabis
that's going to leave the atc's unable
to compete on price
patients will leave the program
they'll be for the cheaper products that
they can get at the recreational stores
that'll jeopardize the atcs and the
therapeutic cannabis program but
importantly it will leave the patients
without the full spectrum of products
they need
and without guidance and without
education and without the supervision
i had suggested at one point to the ways
and means committee not to the whole
committee but to a few select members
that a solution might be
to set aside some of the revenue from
the recreational program to simply
support the atc sufficiently to allow
the atcs to meet the price point of the
state recreational stores but such a
safeguard was not inserted
so in summary hb 1598 does not protect
our therapeutic cannabis program it
places it in jeopardy the profusion of
floor amendments we see on this bill
strongly suggests that this bill still
needs a lot of work and it's for those
reasons that i even though i like i'm in
favor of legalization i still oppose
otpa on this bill and suggest interim
studies so we can work out these
problems and come up with a good bill
because i don't trust the people on the
other side of the wall to fix all these
problems thank you
jay i recognize representative abbas
thank you mr speaker i rise in support
of
hb 5988 the committee's recommendation
of ought to pass as amended
in regards to the atcs there was no
actual physical data or information
presented to the criminal justice and
public safety committee or to the
house ways and means committee
to suggest how many patients who are
legitimately receiving medical treatment
would all of a sudden
stop receiving that legitimate medical
treatment and all of a sudden resort to
recreational drug use if hb 1598 would
become law
there was also no information presented
to either committee
about how many patients would have to be
lost
to the atcs in order for the atc to no
longer be viable
the only opposition that was really
explained or that how it would hurt the
adcs is that it
the
policy put forth by hp 1598 would
compete with the existing monopoly that
the atc's have
on the medical industry
as i said existing monopoly that exists
and the new hampshire state constitution
does not permit a private monopoly such
as the atc's have so if someone were to
challenge that that would be an
interesting to see how that would that
would play out
in respect to the revenue
and i said this before i'm sure people
have heard me say this
and we've all probably heard it from
other individuals
property taxes with the exception of
fuel tax right now property taxes is one
of the complaints that we hear about the
most
this is a opportunity for not just
one caucus of the other this is an
opportunity for this body today
to actually deliver
a reduction
in on property taxes throughout the
entire state it's not talk it's not a
future promise it's not something that
we'll put into the bill later it's
actually in the bill it is in there
right now
in order to deliver on that we need to
on our part we have to push that green
button to do this
if you are not in if you don't want to
support lowering property taxes or if
you feel that lowering property taxes
for some reason is not fair because some
communities or some houses are valued
more than other houses
well
perhaps you push that red button
but if you want to join me and actually
deliver in lower property taxes
throughout the entire state and not just
talk about it join me push that green
button and support the committee's
recommendation about the passes amended
thank you mr speaker remember yield to
questions
no remember it does not yield
chair recognizes representative palmola
to speak against the committee
chair recognizes
representative conley
he waves off
chair recognizes representative ames
thank you mr speaker
so i'm here to speak against the pending
ought to pass motion on house bill 1598
as amended
i want to begin by
agreeing with many who have spoken
for and against this bill
by
saying in different words what they've
said decades of experience
have proven
i believe that legal prohibition of
recreational cannabis fosters a harmful
black market
and high levels of arrests
of marginalized people
maine massachusetts and vermont and many
other states have moved to legalize
with this context and background within
common sense regulatory frameworks
new hampshire does need to join this
movement
away from prohibition
to best practice legalization of the
purchase and sale of cannabis for
recreational adult use in new hampshire
unfortunately however
this bill sets up a legalized
legalization structure
that is unlikely to work
although the amendments just adopted are
welcome
the
i suggest that house bill 1598's
fundamental structural defects
go deep
and cannot be fixed by piecemeal
amendment
the bill's chosen model for legalization
is unprecedented in the united states
it creates
a government-owned retail monopoly
that will be vested in the new hampshire
liquor commission
this state-owned retail monopoly will
then
depend
entirely on a private
interest state supply chain
that will be strictly confined within
new hampshire's borders
due to continuing federal prohibition of
interstate cannabis transactions
this will be totally unlike
the existing retail liquor monopoly held
by the liquor commission
with liquor
there is a worldwide wholesale
supply chain
and a very active cross-border retail
market
the commission
which is officially neutral on this bill
has made clear that it will protect its
premier liquor brand
by not co-co-locating
cannabis stores
with its liquor stores
this new public-private hybrid cannabis
supply and retail system
will be subject to a regulatory system
controlled by the liquor commission
in this peculiar model the liquor
commission is being assigned
dual
and inevitably conflicting roles of
monopoly retailer
and chief government regulator
this house bill 1598 model
resembles hybrid public-private models
that have been tried
in two canadian provinces quebec
and ontario perhaps in other provinces
as well but i don't know that
[Music]
reportedly after struggling with
wasteful disconnects
between private product supply chains
and the demands of government-owned
retail outlets
ontario has given up
on the public ownership components
of its model quebec is still stumbling
along
its production and sales lagging the
other canadian provinces
these adverse canadian experiences
and in contrast the many positive
private market legalization experiences
in the united states
appear to me to demonstrate that
flexible vertical marketing integration
coupled with independent
regulation is needed
to enable canada's cannabis's successful
cultivation processing and sale
house bill 1598's inflexible
legal separation
of publicly owned retail stores
from the rest of the privately owned
supply chain
will likely prevent
any such vertical
marketing integration
the amended bill prohibits liquor
commission retail sale
of so-called cannabis infused food or
drink products including so called
edibles edibles will now
thanks to
an amendment that we
adopted whatever it was an hour ago or
so
cannabis will be part of the with
kind of cannabis edibles will come
within
the frame of the possession limit so
we've gotten over that hurdle and
corrected that deficiency in the in the
bill but the
liquor stores will not be selling or the
cannabis
stores run by the liquor commission will
not be selling edibles to
adult recreational customers
these cannabis infused products are
popular with recreational cannabis
customers
and are thought to make up as much as 40
of cannabis sales in other legalized
states
prohibiting their sale to the
commission's adult use customers
is certain to substantially reduce the
commission's
interest rate
and potential cross-border revenue
the absence of these popular items from
the commission's retail product line
will undermine the commission's ability
to successfully compete
with the multitude of established
private market stores
in each of new hampshire's neighboring
states
informal revenue estimates
previously put forward by the bill's
sponsors
suggested that implementation of this
model in new hampshire could generate
about 250 million dollars annual net
revenue for the state
however
liquor commission testimony before the
ways and means committee
and much more information received from
states and people in the industry
convinced the committee that net annual
revenue after full implementation
would more likely be about one-tenth of
that original estimate
considering the exclusion of
cannabis-infused food or drink products
we now estimate that
in the best case
net revenues will more likely level off
at between 20 million
and 30 million dollars
at the end of a transition period of at
least four years
that will be needed for rulemaking
state staffing
and product and store development
and remember that is the best case
given these limitations proposed revenue
allocations
contained in the amended bill
expressed as percentages after expenses
insignificant excuse me insignificant
amounts
divided among many beneficiaries
the amended bill
de-prioritizes funding for drug misuse
education prevention and treatment
so it will fail to provide more than a
pittance for these essential programs
and non-profit alternative therapeutic
cannabis centers
and you've heard about them from
representative canarch which provide
important services to those seeking
medical help
now number more than 10
they're serving more than 9 000 patients
at last count
and representatives of representatives
excuse me representatives of these
centers
did testify to ways and pains that they
may not survive
if the house bill 1598 model is
implemented
legal counsel for these centers has
further advised that the amended bill's
limited allowance for
for-profit
components of alternative treatment
centers will not work
in short the amended bill fails to put
in place safeguards to ensure survival
of new hampshire's alternative
therapeutic cannabis centers
so in conclusion i feel that
i i believe that house bill 1598 is not
ready for prime time it needs more work
interim study would be a good option to
help move legalization in a better
direction and i hope that you will join
me in voting against otpa thank you mr
speaker does the member yield to
questions
member does not yield
chair recognizes
representative lang
who is the last speaker
thank you mr speaker thank you
colleagues i promise i'll keep this
really really short
the representative from sugar hill was
exactly correct the 2022 unh poll says
74 of new hampshire residents support
legalization that poll went on and said
61 percent
of that poll supports this bill
what does this bill do pretty
straightforward legalization is what
everybody's looking for this truly not
decriminalizes but
stops new hampshire from prosecuting
and arresting our citizens for
possession and use of cannabis
what else does the bill do it does set
up a state monopoly uh readily admitted
it allows the state to be able to sell
cannabis certain counties products what
does that do to revenue no one talked
about revenue revenue estimated from and
it's a very conservative estimate the
revenue for gross sales by the new
hampshire liquor commission was 250
million dollars in sales in the state of
new hampshire that is a conservative
number of that 250 million dollars 50
million dollars would be estimated as
profit we should be used to run the
state stores their first their operating
costs
this bill allocates 4.6 million dollars
to the state liquor stores so they can
open up their first three or four stores
and then from those three or four sales
stores they'll use their revenue to be
able to open up any future stores that
they need
it requires the new hampshire liquor
commission to pay back the citizens of
new hampshire 4.6 million dollars back
to the general fund within five years so
the taxpayer is not on the hook for
anything to start this project
lastly what does it do to the remaining
revenue after operational expenses and
paying back
the citizens of new hampshire the 4.6
million dollars this bill gives direct
tax relief to every property owner in
the state 50 percent
of all net revenue must go against the
363 million dollar swept tax that we ask
every citizen to pay
it directly goes against that to lower
the taxes for every single property
owner
in the state of new hampshire
additionally what else does it do gives
30 percent to pay off the new hampshire
retirement system
4.9 billion dollar debt
the faster we can pay that debt off the
less our citizens are paid in interest
and the less our towns in our state and
city employees will pay for retirement
contributions it automatically will
raise their pay if we get this paid off
faster
lastly it gives money to the
department of health and human services
for drug and alcohol cessation programs
it gives 10 percent of the revenues or
25 million dollars whatever is less so
if we get to the point where we're
making 300 million dollars in net profit
the department of health and human
services will get 25 million dollars
lastly gives five percent to police
officers first responders for training
to teach them to become drug recognition
experts to deal with the incidents on
the job that they'll have to deal with
and we acknowledge there may be some
that they'll be able to better deal with
them and then it gives five percent to
children's mental health programs
through dhhs
so again this is a win across the board
for all the citizens of new hampshire
all
all advocacies are taken care of we gave
in this bill the atcs which are
concerned about lost revenue we gave
them the ability because we found out
from the new hampshire banking
association that not-for-profits can own
for-profit entities underneath them so
we gave them the ability to file for a
for-profit entity underneath them and
allow them to apply for cultivation
manufacturing and transportation
licenses from the liquor commission
again this is a make hole provision we
recognize we'll be in a little bit of
direct competition with the medical
marijuana industry or correction the
therapeutic cannabis
industry
and we will we made provisions for that
to give them an additional revenue
stream to help offset any potential
losses they may have again this bill was
was thoroughly vetted i think i had
drafted close to seven different
amendments that were incorporating at
least two dozen
different uh requests from both sides of
the aisle and they were all incorporated
into this bill you see the bipartisan
nature of this bill when you look at the
representative from dover's and mine
amendment to fix the accidental
illegalization of the
of the um edibles uh i was ready to do
for representative marsha's bill uh
amendment uh
pi if needed because again it made the
bill better it doesn't matter which side
of the aisle the amendment came from if
it made the bill better it was
incorporated into this bill this bill is
a great bipartisan bill and i'd ask you
to please vote green
it's remember yield to questions
remember yields
wait a minute wait a minute
representative
and cali pitts is first
i have a
real question that i i would like asked
did anyone consider
if the state establishing these centers
to sell what is now a federally illegal
drug
would put the federal funding that new
hampshire gets
in many many ways in jeopardy
thank you for the question what i would
tell you is this is that from the new
hampshire banking commission we heard
that the department of treasury has a
department called fincin i think it has
to do with financial crimes
fincin from the banking industry gave
every new hampshire bank directions on
how to deal with cannabis related funds
which are legal federally so apparently
the federal government's already kind of
made up their mind they're not doing
anything with this with these bills with
with the states so um and so i guess the
answer to your question is every
indicator from the federal government is
that they are not going to prosecute or
come after the state any state that has
legalization at this point this member
yields a further question yes
thank you mr speaker thank you
for taking my question i'll be very
quick
if we make laws in this body and we feel
that those laws need to be changed like
edibles need to be added in a year or
two or other provisions that we may need
to oversee to improve the law that we
created would we be able to do that
absolutely thank you sarah
does the member yield a further question
casey
member does not yield
okay
we are at the end of the debate
so
now
i the question is
on the majority committee report of what
passed
as amended
[Music]
representative hamal has asked for a
roll call
is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote
so
the motion before us is the majority
committed report
voter pass has amended the house will be
in order membership meet
be in your seats
on house bill 1598.
this is a roll call vote
the chair recognizes representative almi
for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
if i know that the business model
and the refusal to sell recreational
edibles required by this bill
will only provide at best 15 million a
year to reduce the total
on
multi-billion dollar
property tax
in this state
12 million
a year to reduce
the retirement system debt which i think
i calculated before was going to take
about a thousand years that way
3 million for substance abuse help
and
half that for drug enforcement and
children's
health
systems
each
and if i know that new hampshire can do
better than this
and if i know that passing this state
monopoly model this year will make it
much harder to replace with one that
works next year even if we could get the
edibles into it which are half of the
money
um
surely
i will press the red button so that
another motion can be made thank you
jay recognized representative nunez for
parliamentary inquiry
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker
if i know that along with every cannabis
bill that's come through the legislature
our goal is always to stop arresting
people
and mr speaker media resources and polls
have provided data stating that over 70
percent of granite staters approve of
adult use legalize cannabis
and that we've been trying
unsuccessfully for over 20 years to give
the citizens what they've asked for
mr speaker if i know that hb 1598 can do
just that
and that it can also help our citizens
by directing 50 percent of the revenue
taken in by the state to be applied to
property tax relief reducing the tax
obligations for every taxpayer
and if i also know other provisions in
1598 direct revenue to assist the
overbearing
retirement system debt
and also supports
children's behavioral mental health and
welfare then would i support the
taxpayers
the state and municipal workers and the
kids by pressing the green button thank
you mr speaker
also be in order
the motion before us is the ought to
pass as amended motion on house bill
it's the roll call vote
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you oppose you press the red
button voting stations are open for 30
seconds
so
do
now
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote also attend the
state of the vote
169 voting yay 156 voting a committee
report is adopted
everybody stay in your seats please
we're down to the last bill taking off
consent and is a short debate
committee on finance to which was
referred house bill 1540 fn enact
relative to recording custodial
interrogations having considered the
same report the same with the following
amendment the recommendation that the
bill ought to pass with amendment
representative gerald griffin for the
committee the amendment is 1095-h
printed in house record 12 pages 24.
the question is on the amendment are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say aye
those opposed nay
the amendment is adopted the motion
before us now is ought to pass as
amended
the chair recognizes representative true
to speak against the committee report
thank you mr speaker
mr speaker house bill 540 was passed by
the house on february 16th referred to
finance
and now
here we are again with amendment
the amendment requires
the recording of all custodial
interrogation
the finance committee
found that as amended
this bill has little or no financial
impact
on new hampshire counties and towns
the new hampshire association of police
chiefs
testified that many small towns in new
hampshire
will need to purchase equipment
the new hampshire county attorneys
testified they will need to purchase
additional equipment and hire additional
personnel to comply
since the state of new hampshire is not
funding these additional costs
it is my position
that this downshifting of cost to the
towns and counties
is a violation of article 28a of the new
hampshire constitution
and that is that is why i cannot support
the motion of otpa
i tried to make that point in the past
and i failed
and i do appreciate the opportunity to
fail
one more time
the new hampshire constitution says thou
shalt not downshift
it doesn't say
try not to downshift unless you think
it's for a really good idea
in closing please allow me to quote from
the greatest band to ever come out of
erie pennsylvania
the o'neiders
my friends you just keep doing that
thing you do
thank you mr speaker
recognizes gerald griffin to speak for
the committee report
thank you mr
speaker
mr speaker
this bill
was looked at by finance
and we had some concerns
that we might be passing some costs on
as the bill came to us
it had severe restrictions
on what was an exception to the bill
finance addressed those restrictions
they removed financial impact
as a restriction
and allowed it as a restriction
and they removed it as a pro
prohibited and they allowed it as a
restriction
we considered those small towns
and
we also
worried about whether they had the
equipment
and the costs that it would be for them
to do it
and therefore we basically created a
bill
with exceptions that i think you can
drive a truck through and
i don't think there's any
town that will be impacted by this bill
it doesn't mandate that you do
interrogations it says if you do
interrogations
they need to be
recorded electronically
it doesn't say video recordings
it just says they needed
to be recorded
electronically
and there is exception in the bill
that would allow
exceptions for many many causes
including financial
causes or lack of equipment
so i believe that this is a good bill
it
brings transparency
to the interrogation process
it protects the person in custody
it protects the police
it is overall a very good bill most of
our large cities are already doing
what this bill is asking
all all people
to do
so i hope you will join with me
and and vote to pass this bill with the
amendment
the motion before us is the auto passes
amended motion on house bill 1540.
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say aye
those opposed nay
you guys have it the committee report is
adopted
chair recognizes the member from auburn
representative osborne for the third
reading motion
i resolved that the house now adjourned
from the early session that the business
of the late session be in order at the
present time that the reading of bills
be by title only and resolutions by
caption only and that all bills ordered
a third reading be read a third time by
this resolution and that all titles of
bills be the same as adopted and that
they be passed at the present time and
when the house adjourns today be to meet
at the call of the chair
question the question is on the third
reading motion are you ready for the
question all those in favor say aye
those opposed nay the eyes have an
emotion is adopted
we have a couple of announcements and
one unanimous consent so if everybody
will just stick around for a minute
um
the chair recognizes representative
levesque for an announcement
just wanted to let everybody know that
after before we leave
that there will be a photo opportunity
for those wearing blue and yellow and
sunflowers thank you
chair recognizes representative magliore
for an announcement
thank you mr speaker just want to remind
everybody republicans and democrats
alike
may 22nd the legislative softball game
our charity event to raise money
for children with disabilities for
domestic abuse victims and for homeless
veterans
a truly non-partisan event we hope that
everyone will reach out come everyone
who comes is going to play
coach it's going to be a lot of fun
we're going to have a great time get in
touch with representative lang get in
touch with representative
of representative pete samsich get rep
get in touch with myself we have
t-shirts made 100 percent uh in the
united states
so we hope that you'll all come out
support each other but support these
important organizations
that serve our community so again may
22nd and get in touch with any one of us
uh to sign up thank you
joe recognizes representative lang for
an announcement
thank you mr speaker i want to thank
everybody for the food drive there's it
was a great success the boxes are still
going to be up for about another week
before i collect them so if you're
coming in for committee hearings and you
want to still donate to the food drive
we've raised through the food drive a
little over 3 500 that'll go to our two
charities we have
the democrats on this side have chosen
to do a domestic violence release
shelter program and the republicans on
that side have choose chosen to give
their donation to a homeless veterans
relief program so all the money we raise
are going to go to support those two
charities if you still have food you
want to bring it in it'll help if you
want to do cash donations you can just
drop them in the box and i'll collect it
and we'll add that to the totals i want
to thank everybody i truly appreciate it
the response has been overwhelming and
thank you again
chair recognizes the clerk for
announcement thank you mr speaker two
quick announcements remember if you if
you leave the binax now tests in your uh
mailboxes in the back we will mail them
to you if not if you don't want them to
be mailed to you then please put them in
to the
the box
not the trash bin but the box with the
signs on it second thing please do not
leave a mess at your seats if you if you
have trash take it with you
if you have stuff in your seat pockets
including all the papers it would be
helpful if you could take those and
throw those thank you
what reason is the member rise mr
speaker i would like to address the
house
if i may um what
about an incident are you asking for
unanimous consent
yes
you may continue may begin
mr speaker
today during the floor debates on hb
1609 the fetal protection act i was
disheartened to it
to hear that at least two members laudi
loudly interrupted the member's speech
with the words liar
while the gentleman from stratford spoke
the members who yelled that word
disrespected the gentleman from
stratford and the entire house
as americans we are divided on many
issues
yet we as honorable legislators have a
duty to uphold proper decorum
i would like to apologize
i'm sorry that people
called the member from stratford a liar
when i've known him to be a very hard
working rep
he and i don't agree on everything but
we have worked together very
productively and i have a great deal of
respect for him thank you
chair recognized
chair recognizes representative cannon
for unanimous consent
thank you mr speaker
today is the international transgender
day of visibility it's an annual event
that occurs on march 31st it's dedicated
to celebrating transgender people and
raising awareness of discrimination
faced by transgender people worldwide
as well as a celebration of their
contributions to society
many people like myself representative
butler bunker representative lawton have
hidden from the public for most of our
lives
we chose to hide rather than to cause
societal problems for the people around
us and ourselves
now we celebrate ourselves and people
like us
who have faced our fears
and become visible role models for other
transgender people in the united states
and in countries around the world
yesterday
president biden proclaimed march 31st
2022 is transgender day visibility
the following is a quote from his
proclamation
on this transgender day of visibility we
honor transgender people who are
fighting for freedom equality dignity
and respect
we also celebrate the parents teachers
coaches doctors and other allies who
affirm the identities of their
transgender children and help these
young people reach their potential
[Music]
potential
transgender people are some of the
bravest americans i know
and our nation and the world are
stronger more vibrant and more
prosperous because of them
to transgender americans of all ages i
want you to know that you are so brave
you belong
you have i have your back
i agree with the president
i have met with many brave transgender
youth
young adults parents and communities of
people who are standing up to support
their transgender family members friends
businesses and community leaders
today is a transgender day of visibility
we aren't hiding anymore
we are very active
and visible part of our communities and
our state thank you
[Applause]
more reason to remember rise i request
that representative cannon's remarks be
placed in the permanent journal
without objection
representative osborne moves that the
house stand in recess for the purpose of
introduction of bills enrolled bills
amendments and rule build reports
receiving messages i ready for the
question
all those in favor say aye
that's opposed nay
the motion is the motion is adopted the
house is in recess to the call of the
chair
you